man Jim Cramer on CNBC totally lost the
plot in a long tirade he called for the
military to run
government-enforced mandatory
vaccinations he it was it was pretty
intense this was not some light thing
like maybe we should have the military
come out and you know offer up people
Services no no he was like everybody
should be forced to do it and if you
don't want to do it go to court and then
file your con chances conscientious
objector status and we'll have the
military run it
fauci came out and he said it's time you
know he said we might not have to lock
down but prepare for the worst when
asked he said we're gonna have lockdowns
don't worry it'll be temporary and Joe
Biden said lockdowns will not be
necessary
for now if everyone gets the vaccine and
wears their masks so I'll make this
prediction you know I don't like making
predictions Because the Internet loses
their minds when I do and uh I'm just
you know sometimes wrong but how about
this I think we're going to see
lockdowns again
I think Omicron is here it's being
reported in San Francisco
I think we're gonna see lockdowns I
think it's going to be mostly in blue
States I certainly think Florida and
Texas are going to say shove off but I
think New York California Illinois many
of these blue states are going to come
out and they're going to be like we've
got to do it again and I would not be
surprised if the governors of these
states then kill more elderly people
we talked about the uh the Hope
experiment the um what was this guy's
name what was the guy's name Carl
Richter or something yeah so I don't
know something like that he basically
put rats in a vet in a cylinder full of
water and within 15 minutes they give up
they can't swim they die then he did
another experiment where he took a map
of just before they drowned dries him
off put him back in the second time
because of hope they swam for I think 60
hours was a total they wouldn't give up
because they believed this hand might
come and save me again so I've been
saying for a while now that they've
reduced the lockdowns they'll come back
and they'll come back substantially
worse so we're gonna talk about all that
we got a cool group here we got rev here
you want to introduce yourself man yeah
yeah I'm a journalist uh mostly writing
for the New York Post and other outlets
as well writing about kovid mandates
crime identity politics but lately a lot
about covid and mandates and young
people especially the side effects that
young people are facing and the risks
with mandating vaccines for school
children and all of what's happening
right now in Europe and across North
America right on man thanks for coming
we got a lot to talk about we got Luke
so I'm here watching the chat and I want
to shout out the person that just said
no rootkowski we pukowski really
appreciate that very much I appreciate
you guys and if you guys want to support
me you can by checking out my t-shirt
store it of course is
thebestpoliticalshirts.com and you can
buy shirts like the one I'm wearing
right now that says if you trust the
government you don't know history I
think an important lesson that Jim
Cramer should really learn they make
great gifts and gag ideas the best
politicalshirts.com thanks for having me
that is a statement on your shirt I
think a lot about if I didn't have the
knowledge of what Nazis and what the
Nazis have done that this would be a
totally different experience if I didn't
know that this is actually not this
particular but it has happened in the
past where they genially put you on a
train and take you somewhere to relocate
Ian wait until you find out what the
Communists did and hold on too there's a
really great quote what the Nazis did
was legal yeah what what uh uh Schindler
and other people did trying to protect
Jews was illegal what they did was
against the law what's the United States
United States did to the Japanese with
the internment camps was legal what the
Communists did they all justify it so uh
let's make sure we don't confuse
legality with morality exactly yeah
definitely yeah so I'm really excited
for this evening because uh the talk
about lockdowns again talk about this
new variant is really distressing so
hopefully we can find some kind of
closure on that but before we get
started my friends we have an awesome
sponsor we have double we have solar
water heater.com a very very simple
product you know I'm really excited we
had uh the light bug the other day and
now we have the solar water heater these
are such simple things to promote that
it's it's very easy it's literally a
solar water heater that's it you put
water in it you put it in the sun it
Heats your water up it can kill
sterilize water you can use it for
making coffee tea and we were actually
talking about this we were like you know
where would you need something like this
I don't think you got to think of it
like an apocalypse thing but you could
but it's more of like you're having a
picnic in you know Central Park or
something and you want to have a cup of
coffee or tea you just lay this thing
out in the sun it heats up your water in
seconds they say go to solar water
heater.com you get 50 off and you can
get another 25 off by putting in the
promo code timcast25 again solar water
heater.com this thing's pretty red I'm
excited for it we'll try it out and uh
rather simple again timcast25 but don't
forget head over to timcast.com become a
member and you'll get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast which we will have
for you tonight around 11 or so p.m you
don't want to miss it we usually go get
a little Rowdy not so much family
friendly because it's the after it's the
after show it's the after party but as a
member of Tim Caster helping support all
of our journalists so you know we have a
bunch of stories we put up all the time
we have investigative we have breaking
news we have on the ground reporting
happening we had elad he's going you
know traveling to cover some of these
big protests and we have that stuff uh
stuff up all the time and it's all
thanks to you as members so don't forget
you can also like this video subscribe
to this Channel smash the like button
check out we got the no step on a step
on snack and find out shirt pinned in
the chat you can get that if you want it
and uh share the video help support uh
the show and we don't have the marketing
budget of CNN but we do have Grassroots
power from all of you guys let's jump
over that first story get right into it
Joe Biden be quiet I am I am offended
that Joe Biden started talking right as
I'm trying to start this side we're
gonna mute that psych out here Joe
CNBC host suggests Nationwide vaccine
mandate have the military run I really
love this story from the hill because
Jim Cramer didn't suggest anything he
demanded it he didn't say maybe we uh
you know we have a national vaccine
mandate no he was literally like this is
on the White House in Biden everyone's
got to do this and if you don't you go
to court and try and prove your objector
status and it's it's rather crazy I'll
jump right to this we have this tweet
here with this video I'll jump right to
the end
so you can hear him get to the having
the military run this thing nobody wants
to be the bad guy He's the bad guy but
back then anyone who refused to get
vaccinated would get ratted out
immediately because we knew that person
could hurt other people the common wheel
was a common wheel
now engaged in a similar struggle with
Kobe what was that it means to Breathe
No I can't it the way he's slurring his
speech I'm actually wondering massive
threatening attention no oh that's true
too that's true
let's play it because Eisenhower would
be a guest we have immuno compromised
people who are incubators for every
variant to come walking around lawfully
unvaccinated that's psychotic we have
companies that have tried hard to get
people vaccinated now backing down we
have Governors who want to be president
by grandstanding on a foolish State's
right issue the right to get sick and
get other people sick
so it's time to admit that we have to go
to war against covet require vaccination
universally have a military run it if
you don't want to get vaccinated you
better be ready to prove your
conscientious object your status in
court
you know I gotta say uh he's he's
slurring pretty crazy yeah it's like
that I mean totally as an aside like I'm
not trying to say this disrespectfully
that that weird circular wheel what was
he saying I don't know I don't know
compared to two years ago that you're
totally right I haven't watched him in a
long time and he's what he's reading a
teleprompter but the way he said object
or it I feel like
I thought he was having a stroke no joke
no joke like the weight starts slurring
and like losing it but anyway to the
point of his politics a bunch of crazy
stuff we'll have the military running oh
you're just thrown it out there we just
have the military take control and go
Marshall like it's crazy the Casualty
that he uh spoke with there and and it
makes absolutely no sense by the way
like segregating between unvaccinated
and vaccinated when we know that there
are several studies showing that the
vaccine efficacy
lasts about six seven months against
infection and so after about six seven
months a vaccinated person is just as
likely to get infected and transmit
covet as an infected person as a as an
unvaccinated person several studies show
this so mandating the stuff makes no
sense because then you're going to have
a group of people that has the same
level of infection and transmission
rates after a certain amount of months
so it's just a matter of buying US time
so yeah so um I mean obviously been
talking about boosters for a long time
and it's weird because you have like
there was a period where if you said the
efficacy was waning you'd get banned on
social media if Dave Rubin being a great
example where he tweeted out you know
it's not working the way they promised
and sooner or later they're going to
call for boosters and he got to spend on
Twitter for it and now sure enough yeah
they've already been saying and I think
in Israel they're on a number shot
number five yeah shot number five which
needs to be mandated a part of their
digital vaccine passport social credit
score system that they implemented in
that country which is absolutely absurd
Jim Cramer here here just proved how
much of an establishment hack he is he's
a bear Stern shill showing off his best
boot licking on National Television
which is embarrassing for this country I
mean he went full commie it's psychotic
behavior he wants to throw people in
jail in court and have the military men
who are used to fighting armies force
people to take a medication that might
not be right for them that might hurt
them that some medical professionals are
telling some individuals based on their
own medical history that they can't take
I mean are you freaking kidding me and
again Jim Cramer uh maybe I don't know
maybe he was trying to boost up a big
Pharma Stocks by doing this I don't know
what he was thinking but I don't trust
this man's Financial advice especially
when it came to bear Stearns I didn't
trust his financial advice when it came
to bitcoin when he announced he sold
most of his Bitcoin on June 21st of 21st
of this year Bitcoin was about thirty
two thousand dollars Bitcoin right now
is about 57 000 so uh his financial
advice hasn't been there uh his social
critique and political involvement now
is full fascistic and as dangerous as it
is stupid in my opinion maybe you're
right um I mean so Jim Cramer's show is
like Stock Show he talks about finances
we got the story from Barons this is
from today modernistock tanks after
losing a patent dispute here's what
comes next I don't really care what
comes next moderna dropped 10 percent
now this is today that speech he gave
was from Monday but maybe you're a guy
who's talking Finance maybe you're a guy
who gives bad advice and maybe you use
your show to try and push and pump and
dump and things like that I'm not saying
he does but
I mean it's possible yeah well the
modernist stock went down because the
CEO came out a few days ago and said
that the vaccine doesn't have that good
Effectiveness when it comes to this new
omnicron variant allegedly and as soon
as he said that the stocks go down he
soon came after that statement and made
another statement saying that we need
double booster shots in order to
successfully fight this new omnicron
variant which just appeared in the
United States from a fully vaccinated
person in San Francisco California okay
well hold on you're you're jumping the
gun here Luke you're jumping the gun
Barons is reporting the stock fell
because a federal circuit court of
appeals a panel of three judges upheld a
ruling against the biotech company in a
decision on patents that Arbutus
biopharma that it owns the patents in
question regard lipid nanoparticles
which are used to deliver mRNA to cell
safely which basically means if you've
got stock in moderna they don't own the
rights to that product and I can only
imagine they're going to have to pay out
some kind of portion of their revenue to
the rights holder on this regard yeah
that plus two judges now ruling against
Biden's vaccine mandate plus his latest
statements all of course are having a
kind of Crescendo moment and also with
the Federal Reserve screaming saying hey
this is going to hurt us financially
with this new variant no no no no no no
the Federal Reserve printing money out
of thin air is going to hurt us
financially as they're the ones causing
inflation as they're the ones causing
the larger economic problems and they're
trying to blame it on this new variant
omnicron variant which again we're still
learning about all the details omnicron
whatever yeah are you choosing Joe
Biden's version yes yes what the
President says is Gospel and we should
always trust and believe them no matter
what I would love to rename it to
omnicron that's great let's just call it
omnicron we might as well I mean Biden's
the authority on this isn't he yeah he's
not a withered husk of a former of a
former self no he's a president yeah he
doesn't have metal stints inside of his
brain holding up major blood clots you
know this idea by the way that new
variants are going to come and they're
going to lead to more booster shots was
considered to be absolute conspiracy at
the beginning of the pandemic it was
this is a two-shot vaccine and I don't
know if you guys saw on Twitter Eric
topple the big medical expert that the
left you know often uses as somebody
who's reliable for this information he
came out yesterday with a tweet saying
this is a three-shot vaccine and he's
considered like the one of the biggest
most reliable experts on vaccines
um there's one story I was looking at
recently by the way which shows how
ineffective vaccines are against
infection the Ottawa Senators and NHL
hockey team 100 vaccination rate and now
40 percent of the team just tested
positive for covid what is that which
but so so the issue is are we dealing
with variants that are that the vaccines
struggle to deal with
I I've heard varying opinions I I have
heard that because of Delta and omnicron
that these are new variants and the
vaccine have a limited coverage for the
various pathogens that they attempt to
protect against I I have no idea how the
biological mechanism works but we but
it's absolutely objectively true that
the protection against infection is
completely short-lived it's only a few
months well let's make sure we have the
distinction right so to say the vaccines
don't you know aren't working well hold
on the issue is they don't work long
enough yes and that's that's not I don't
I'm you know I'm gonna say I'm gonna say
oh no they work forever yeah they work
you go go talk to your doctor because
they work forever I'm kidding by the way
my point is
if you if you have all of the mainstream
media coming out and saying the efficacy
is waning and now you need three shots a
booster is your fourth shot it's it's
fouchy it's the modernist CEOs the guys
who are saying you need more boosters
not not us the narrative that they are
pushing that capacity to then is
breaking confidence in the efficacy of
the vaccines so what I said you know
when we saw um LeBron James
a double vexed gets covered
New York Daily News wrote in the first
sentence not even the the king is immune
to covid-19 and I was like
what if he was vaccinated so when they
said that it was a really weird
cognitive dissonance I think for regular
people because people call people call
vaccines immunization right they would
be like did you get immunized from you
know this or whatever or did you go you
got to get you got immunized from yellow
fever when I went and got my vaccines
for going to Venezuela they started
getting immunized it was synonymous yeah
yeah and maybe it's a colloquial thing
like oh we don't think it's a guarantee
it'll prevent yellow fever or Hep or
something like that but if LeBron James
got the vaccine as he was supposed to do
it and he still gets it and Dan bongino
gets the vaccine because he you know he
had lymphoma and then he still gets it
the problem is
all of your data goes out the window
this is why I'm always just like go talk
to a doctor man I don't want I don't
want liability from anybody making
decisions off of you know I'm not going
to give advice on this but the issue
then is people will be bewildered what
are you supposed to do when you have a
news story coming out literally LeBron
James fully vax gets covered Dan majino
folivax gets covered who are the
politicians who got it and they were
fully vexed yeah we keep having these
high profile stories and as you pointed
out would you say 40 of the NHL 40 of
the Ottawa Senators a top NHL team just
tested positive for covet even though
100 of the team is vaccinated and if you
talk to top medical experts like like in
in my writing when I talk about covet
I'd be very careful like when I try to
publish stuff if I don't back it up with
expert opinion with trained experts then
it becomes an issue but
um uh it's worth mentioning by the way
we're talking about vaccines that the
protection against death remains uh
durable after several months it's the
it's the protection against infection
that is very short-lived
well still there's a lot of the science
that we haven't figured out and there's
a lot of different political beliefs but
when we have you know large medical
institutions along with Dr fauci coming
out from the very beginning of this and
saying 100 safe and effective just do
this one time and everything will go
back to normal that doesn't build trust
that doesn't build anyone who's going to
willingly now be like okay yeah sure
I'll believe you this time or this time
and and they did it to themselves they
created a situation where it's very hard
to believe anything coming out of their
mouth because it keeps changing and if
it does you have to admit it's changed
you have to take accountability you have
to take responsibility for your words
and they haven't been doing any of that
Dr fauci is afraid of doing any kind of
interviews with anyone who even views
any kind of different political
circumstance differently than he does
and if he's the nation's doctor he's not
supposed to be political but he's been
political from the very beginning he was
saying black lives matter protests are
great anti-lockdown protests bad they're
causing the spread black lives matter
matter protests are the ones that are
slowing the spread and again you can't
have both and they've been changing the
definitions of vaccines they've been
changing the definitions of herd
immunity and I think it's important for
all of us to admit we don't know what's
going on here I'm not a medical
professional I'm not a medical doctor
we're not here giving medical advice but
at the same time we're here to tell you
everyone who's telling you that they
know exactly what's Happening Here is
full of crap that's I think that's a
great Point uh what I said I've said
this before and I'll say it again I'm
not a scientist I'm not a doctor I can't
give advice on that but I am an expert
in Freedom and I think one of the issues
that we keep we fall into is which be
careful there should not be government
mandated medical procedures that that's
about it and and you want to come to me
and say Jim Cramer he's like oh but we
have you know this reason and that
reason I'm like government ain't gonna
tell me what medical producers I got to
have because you have to think uh think
about what it means philosophically if
we move to a point where the government
can mandate any of this by force okay
well you know um people who have
neuralink cybernetic implants have an
advantage ah here's a better one people
who have the Vera chip implant well it's
safer because when they get stopped by
police the police don't have to search
for ID when they get pulled over their
ID's right with them we will reduce
crime and end the crime pandemic if
everyone just gets their Vera chip get
that chip injected into your hand what
happens when a criminal gets up and
gives a false name crime gets worse we
can't give the government the ability to
just say here's the medical procedure
you have to undergo because it's it's
going to help make you safer or save
lives that's it one of the worst
examples of this by the Recently I don't
know if you heard about this 44 000
students in LA are about to lose their
right to have in-person education
because they miss the vaccine deadline
yeah in Los Angeles the LA Times
reported on this 40 44 000 students now
are about to move to online schooling
only because they didn't get vaccinated
and that sounds like a great reset huh
you know stopping people from going in
person and uh let's let's talk about
okay so this is where we are in the
United States with Jim Cramer saying we
want you know he wants the military to
enforce us so let's let's talk about
what that'll look like and the biggest
thing you need to be worried about my
friends are the propagandists
I can only tell you this
we use a wonderful little product called
newsguard and I've been criticized for
using it because uh who funds it Luke go
get Bill Gates oh heavens Bill Gates
provides fun it's through Microsoft
right or him directly uh I'm not sure I
I don't I don't think so uh so I use
this on purpose as sort of uh to make a
point if I use a news source that makes
a claim and then I highlight that claim
and you accuse me of being fake news I
just say oh don't look at me ask Bill
Gates right uh oh are they the
conspiracy theorists now here's a story
we have from the guardian Northern
Territory police arrest three people who
escaped from Howard Springs covid
quarantine facility Trio allegedly
jumped the fence at the Open Air Center
near Darwin early on Wednesday you want
to know what the best part is
do you know what the name of the
Howard's do you know what type of
facility the Howard Springs facility is
good no no give me the lit the exact
statement don't no hyperbole literally
what is the Howard Springs facility
anybody
literal not made up come on come on come
on what has the Australian government
called it
you guys don't know this no no
no no they call it a quarantine Camp I
didn't think that was very difficult but
I guess you guys didn't know I don't
know they're now calling it the center
for National resilience what police and
staff at the center for National
resilience oh I'm sorry that's probably
I probably got that wrong okay that's
probably just where they're doing the
investigation from the police and staff
at the center for National resilience
are currently confirming the absconders
identities prior to releasing further
information they say it's a large
open-air facility for quarantining
people
the alleged escape the absconders
so there are people being brought to
these facilities
voluntarily uh is it voluntary do we
know well but they're not able to leave
voluntarily apparently it doesn't look
voluntarily if they have to escape then
there's not a voluntary exit strategy
well that I know of
yeah so let's get into the the
propagandists uh this one's a little too
personal for me I've been harping on
this for a minute but I want to make
this very concise for you guys so you
can understand what's going on in
Australia we I have this series of
tweets that break down what's happening
in Australia very simply I said don't
forget if the chief minister says you
can't leave your home even to get food
thanks the Army for their trucks used to
transport covet suspects and you get
arrested if you try to leave the camp
Jesse's single and Colette say it's a
conspiracy theory
so here we go here's one article under
that lockdown residents could only leave
home for five reasons including
essential shopping essential work
providing or receiving care exercise and
obtaining medical treatment Gunner has
announced binjari and rockhold residents
now cannot leave their homes unless for
medical reasons or in an emergency that
means you can't leave for food we have
this from gravian Chief Minister Gunner
the Army is now transferring positive
covet cases and contacts in Northern
Territory Australia to quarantine camps
by army trucks and finally NT police
arrest three people who escaped from
Howard Springs covid quarantine facility
the propaganda and the men and those
supporting the the state narrative in
this regard is probably the scariest
thing to me because what ended up
happening today was Jesse single wrote
this entirely fabricated story about me
claiming that I was like a conspiracy
theorist or something based on my tweets
literally quoting
abc.net dot a u which is to say 38
people were transported by Army a truck
to the quarantine facilities I never sat
by with guns drawn or by force or
anything like that he then writes this
big article that's completely fake
seemingly just to kind of discredit me
now of course I know that's personal and
I I take a a emotional issue with it but
I decided to put together these three
sources which I included the links to
all of these stories on Twitter and
surprise surprise many people didn't
know this was real so a lot of people
engaging in the Twitter spat I had with
Jesse see these three stories and their
response immediately was no way that's
real because if you read these
propaganda stories from like Colette or
Jesse you'd think I made it up when in
fact it's all News Guard certified
sources in Australia they have police
and military setting up checkpoints and
locking down people in their homes the
chief minister has said you cannot leave
your home for these reasons for for the
normal lockdown reasons meaning no food
he then said I'd like to thank the Prime
Minister for the ADF personnel and army
trucks to transport the covet cases and
the suspected cases and close contacts
to the Howard Springs facility all of
that was said from his mouth
I feel like Colette is kind of going the
way of um the mainstream media which is
a little bit troubling and I think it's
a really good reminder that we need to
be incredibly critical of all of our
sources even if we think that they're
mostly or some percentage in agreement
with us ideologically it's also pretty
terrifying what's what's happening in
Australia where the government
previously disarmed the citizenry very
interestingly no one's really bringing
up how gun confiscation worked really
well in Australia anymore I remember
hearing about that a few months ago I I
don't hear about that right now ain't
nobody in Australia would take up arms
against what's going on probably but but
still I think it's a factor worth
considering here but when it came to
these three escapees I remember seeing a
news report showing how police officers
were closing down roads and inspecting
every single vehicle searching
everyone's cars to make sure that no one
was hiding trying to make these people
uh get away from the larger area so they
they caught these people but but this is
this is again absolutely huge powers
that the government is granting itself
in the name of a tragedy that that of
course has historically gone down with
people exploiting uh really bad events
for their own personal powers and the
powers that they have in Australia I
mean the authorities there have rushed
through laws that give them the ability
to control people's social media
accounts to hack their accounts to see
everything that they're doing to deny
them the ability to be able to walk into
businesses heavy fines for not wearing a
mask heavy fines for going to protests
jail time for people organizing protests
and when you when you're seeing human
rights eviscerated to such extent where
you can't even voice an opinion against
the government without having the
government knocking on your door saying
we want to control your social media we
now have the ability to post as you when
we want we have the ability to know
every little detail about your life that
is a dangerous
power that you have given the government
that of course it routinely historically
always abuses I want to give a special
shout out to Colette and to Jesse single
too because if there's one thing they
accomplished in making up fake stories
about me or lying is that they've just
gotten me to cover the issue in Greater
detail more and more I love it so I mean
it look it was initially I tweeted
concentration camp in reference to
Howard Springs as kind of like a jokey
trolley thing and Claire decided to go
nuts on it so I doubled down and now
we're at the point where I've covered
this in great detail and it's only
getting worse now there's man hunts for
people who are escaping from this uh
quarantine facility and uh and Jesse
decides to write a completely fabricated
narrative about me based on a tweet
without doing any research that's that's
the funniest thing about it and in turn
I obviously get mad about it and then we
cover the story in Greater detail once
again simplifying that in Australia they
are rounding people up with the
assistance of the military and the chief
minister is thanking them for the
assistance sending them to a camp where
they're trying to escape is Claire in
Australia right now clearly is so is she
in a position now where she got online I
was like you're right Tim what the
government's doing here is horrible we
need to do with that they'd come
knocking on her door yep probably yeah
of course I mean there's incredible
videos showing police officers showing
up at people's doors banging demanding
saying did you post this on the internet
were you here at this protest did you
dare have a voice against the state
intimidating people harassing people not
just protesters journalists like uh what
What's his name yemi uh I forgot it
yeah yeah uh
avi's been doing really incredible work
he had police show up at his door he's
routinely detained for even trying to
report on these protests as an official
member of the press so when you have you
know intimidation of of Journalism when
you have have the suppression of
people's voices when you have the
suppression of protests when you have
the suppressions of people's speech you
have a situation that is absolutely
orwellian destructive dangerous and the
opposite of anything Progressive that
anyone could even imagine want to know
the best part is about these three
people who escaped they were teenagers
and they had tested negative
the Australian government took three
teenagers from the banjar community
brought them to a quarantine facility
when they were negative for covet tested
them they were negative and then when
these three teens escaped the police
were sent out to investigate hunt them
down and arrest them set up roadblocks
are they there though if they're
negative yeah they were near someone I I
have to wonder about the Australian
government bringing not people without
kovid to a quarantine camp where they're
not allowed to leave and then you have
to imagine these teenagers are probably
thinking I don't want to get covid yeah
and they're like you're negative they're
like good let me go no wait were they
positive maybe first and then they were
negative
so what the it's possible but the
minister said close contacts so that
means like right okay well you know we
got uh you know my brother's downstairs
you are officially a close contact
they'd come to your house and arrest you
and be like well you know you were close
contact with this person you might be
like I didn't see that person I know
what you're talking about too bad the
best part about it is how they say
they're not doing it by force and now
you have all of these I swear look
people need to understand
it's a known fact that governments use
sock puppetry on social media the bot
accounts I'm not saying every person's a
bot but they do they do this and it's
funny to see the propagandists coming
out and tweeting it's been confirmed
this people are not being taken by force
and I'm like are you kidding then why
are they escaping like they're they're
voluntarily showing up and then trying
to break out that makes literally no
sense more importantly they voluntarily
voluntarily show up but can't
voluntarily leave how about we'll just
call it that okay the Australian
government is offering free rides and
army trucks to the quarantine facility
where people aren't allowed to leave by
threat of arrest is that it is that are
we good now do you think it's possible
they just don't tell them that they
can't leave once they get there and are
they maybe misleading that's definitely
possible I think it is completely
unreasonable to make the argument that
when the minister comes out and says you
can't leave your house to eat and we're
going to take people with by army truck
to quarantine facilities where they will
be arrested if they escape the idea that
they were voluntarily going to this
place is absurd you know I don't like is
the way the Australian police interact
with the citizenry like gorillas
attacking like a wounded lamb like they
just walk up on people no fear like
their arms are out like they're about to
Grapple so like they're not afraid of
getting shot in the chest because
they've disarmed the populace and they
just like stumble towards humans and
like use their Mass to like squeeze them
it's disgusting one question I have
about the Australian camps is our
vaccinated people able to get into these
camps do they detain those people too
yeah probably for sure positive yeah or
if they're a suspect
one of the big things too and we'll get
into this in a little in just a second
is that
um there's new travel restrictions where
uh Biden wants to implement them that no
matter your vaccination status if you
travel into the country you've got to
quarantine for a week you've got to have
a negative test before traveling and all
of these like
I don't know what's uh what's the word
for for the the zealots all of these
like hardcore government mandate zealots
are like what do you mean I've got to
take a test in quarantine I'm double
vexed and one guy tweeted like I'm
double vexed and boosted I refuse to be
treated like these dewormer people it's
like what did you think was gonna happen
do you bro
get your subscription now promo code
fauci ouchi to your monthly vaccine
booster
look I think if people want if people
are concerned about their health you go
and talk to a doctor about it I think
covet is very very serious I got it and
boy was it bad but I think the problem
is they keep trying to centralize
everything they keep trying to say we
have an idea this one thing will solve
the problem when in reality it's gonna
be a multi-faceted approach that solves
this it's not polio this Jim Cramer guy
acted like it's polio like like we're
dealing with polio any any and then he
was like so he said polio is horrible
polio was horrible so we need to use
vaccines against covet like complete
non-sequitur irrelevance also other
vaccines for polio and smallpox they
took years to get men wasn't it 15 plus
years some were like five or six years
others like 15 years but never broke
before has it been right away as it has
been with covid oh so they didn't rush
out a vaccine for no no no no no and
there's also the danger of of rushing
something that will have an effect that
of course will stop the natural
progression of a virus and potentially
even make it worse that's what some
scientists are speculating right that
this intervention could actually cause
to a worse situation another different
variant that could hurt the world even
more which if you're thinking about how
the state has been using this problem to
help their friends to conduct the
largest transfer of wealth and recorded
human history to empower themselves with
god-like authority over the population I
would think that they would have an
interest in making this situation worse
personally myself but that is just my
own perspective my own personal opinion
some scientists are speculating this as
well but again the data the science it's
still all coming in it still really
hasn't been figured out but to jump to
conclusions to say we need
authoritarianism we need to tyranny to
solve this problem is absolutely
ridiculous it's a stupid idea and it's
an idea that Joe Rogan argued recently
as hurting more people than actually
helping more people and I think that
argument has a lot of Merit to it yeah
I'm still surprised how many people say
that the vaccines are a way to end the
pandemic that they stop the spread of
covid like so many people still say that
it's like no no it's mainstream science
that that's not the case that it slows
the spread temporarily that's the most
accurate way to say it we've got let's
let's uh let me see if I can pull this
uh let me see if I can find this here we
go we got this story from news uh from
Sky News Omicron variant highly
infectious and booster Jabs may need
double dose says moderna CEO it is a
official
big Pharma narrative
Sky News that you will need to get a
double dose of the booster because of
the new variant so there there's there's
no slowing this there's a slowing the
spread I guess but there's no stopping
it if this is our plan of action and
you've got a mainstream uh narrative
from a lot of these people just get it's
like you mentioned earlier Luke they say
just get the first shot and then we're
good everyone will be fine they said in
New York City the Mandate was one shot
at least now it's you know they're
saying okay well now you get then it was
get two doses for fully vaccinated then
they said we gotta get your booster now
they're saying no no the third shot is
not a booster it's a normal part of the
whole vaccine process and now Imagine
This imagine you got three shots already
and they're saying that's not a booster
the CEO of moderna is now saying you
will need two more shots
because of homicron
it's like a Rainmaker selling umbrellas
that's my personal perspective on it but
but again we have to understand who does
this kind of benefit here where's the
accountability where's the oversight
where's people saying hey let's actually
take a look at this and and let's maybe
see if some people are maybe motivated
more by profit than they are about
General Health and if we are interested
in General Health shouldn't we have
conversations about obesity shouldn't we
have conversations about diet and if you
want to have a totalitarian response to
this sure but if you're going to be
attacking anyone it should be maybe KFC
McDonald's Burger King especially if
you're caring about People's Health uh
but but again uh it's it's ridiculous to
even think about it that way uh and and
again people's health is important and
the discussions about exercise vitamin D
getting proper sleep not being stressed
out making sure that you're living a
life that is a healthy happy one rather
than just a wage slave one where you're
indoctrinated by just horrible ideas and
horrible foods that go into your system
and make you a crappy unhealthy unhappy
person you know we if we want to start
those conversations we should have them
and I think we would have a far better
effect at helping people when it comes
to making people healthier than we would
by just giving all of our full faith to
Big Pharma because as we know they're
treated like our overlords right now
I'm not surprised that this CEO of a
pharmaceutical company is suggesting
that his vaccine is the is the way to go
forward no no no no no
I'm not surprised that he's saying you
actually need two yeah okay I'm a window
maker and have you considered putting
two windows in the same place the people
when there's a Health crisis you don't
want to be looking to your
pharmaceutical CEOs for the The Way
Forward necessarily we sound like such
leftists yeah these big corporations are
just trying to turn a profit exploiting
the Health crisis and we should
yeah I mean they were ready
yeah where where where are the uh this
is the problem I have with like the left
is that when we've heard of the left we
are quite literally referring to leftist
populists and the establishment because
for whatever reason they're aligned on
this one
you take a look at the most prominent
personalities they have and they agree
on all this stuff and I'm like yo how
come you guys are pro-big Pharma now
maybe it's because quite simply the new
generation of leftists they were you
know teenagers 10 years ago so when they
Occupy Wall Street types were out there
saying like big Pharma is bad those
people are now in their mid to late 30s
and these 20-something-year-olds who are
on YouTube and pushing this Politics the
far left were born into a world where
big farm is actually good Martin shkreli
awesome guy apparently I guess that's
their position okay sure and and the
record of some of these companies record
fines bribing doctors bribing Regulators
buying off corporate media I can name a
lot of individuals I could name a lot of
multinational corporations that of
course were guilty of this but but they
have a criminal past they're liable for
causing real life human harm before and
for people to just to give them a pass
to a blind a trust because you know
there's a tragedy that's being exploited
here is something that is worrying
personally myself that that I am
concerned about for my own personal
perspective also the way that they're
funding research too like I was
listening to this one cardiologist in
the UK that Majid Nawaz was interviewing
by the way I don't know if you've seen
his content lately on Twitter he's been
great on this and the cardiologist was
saying that 66 of academic research done
on medical issues is funded by drug
companies so that creates a huge bias so
a number of researchers are unable to
publish certain kind of research that
goes against the efficacy of a certain
drug that can lead to I think Joe was
pointing out recently on his podcast Joe
Rogan and several drugs dozens of drugs
that have been pulled off the market
that were initially approved and led to
so many excess deaths and injuries and
that was because the studies that were
done that showed the efficacy were
tainted by this influence from the drug
industry and it led to so many deaths I
mean ever you guys have seen the brought
to you by moderna Montage oh yeah oh
yeah CNN's new day brought to you by by
Pfizer and that shows like all the media
saying that yeah man when you have
commercials I think the United States is
one of only if like what I think like
two countries that allow commercials for
drugs and the best part about it I love
this is that they don't tell what the
drugs do Flor Nostrand call your doctor
to see if it's right for you like they
won't tell you what it is
but they want you to buy it yeah they'll
show like an old woman and man dancing
in the field in a slow motion this could
be you if you just take our drugs
restless leg syndrome we have a solution
and then side effects include
that are other companies sells you take
our medicine are you feeling stressed
it's like this it's a joke like people
do sketches where it's like side effects
may include you know explosive diarrhea
but like I was actually I saw an ad
recently for some medication where they
actually said I I I I verbally exclaimed
in my living room when we were watching
some show and it was like get this
treatment and the side effects include
like bleeding heart or something it's
like some ridiculous thing where it was
like you know blood clots and you know
deep vein thrombosis and other and like
cardiac arrest and I was like why would
you take that it was like do you have
you know irritable bowel syndrome take
this thing that can stop your heart and
it's like maybe not I don't know maybe
you just gotta go to the bathroom and
you know like because that side effects
are crazy I don't know man but but you
know what you know what far be it from
me right if somebody's got some kind of
you know disease and they're suffering
and they say I'll take the risk if it
makes my life better that's between them
their doctor ultimately they make a
choice about what's right for them not
commercials you're right the United
States and New Zealand are the only
countries in the world that allow drug
advertising on commercials right now and
it's pretty much all you see especially
if you watch the corporate media you
just see Pharma ad after Pharma ad after
farmer ad now again we also have to be
intellectually honest here not all of
big pharma's evil some of the stuff that
they do produce does really help people
has revolutionized medicine and has
changed people's lives for the better we
have to admit that on a certain level
but there is a very Sinister nasty
disgusting element of it that literally
profits off of human suffering rather
cures the symptoms then the cause and is
knowingly making money hiding real cures
because of someone sitting at an office
saying I prefer money over human life we
saw that with the opioid epidemic we saw
that with institutions in this country
being bought out by big Pharma that
literally turned a huge portion of this
country into heroin addicts knowingly
because of big money and when you have
that much of power that much influence
that much harm caused by this industry
I'm sorry you don't have my faith you
don't have my personal belief system in
you you don't I'm not going to give you
the benefit of the doubt you don't
deserve it okay Bernie bro it's true
it's true then you got the prison
industrial complex saying these working
class you know family men who lost their
jobs to the factories being shipped
overseas who then got hooked on opioids
should go to prison for it and the
police with smiles on their faces
kicking the doors of the victims Working
Class People in this country and send
them to jail yep yeah the whole system
but you know the problem is yo I can see
it right Luke can see it we can all see
it big pharmaceutical companies
exploiting a crisis exploiting pain
pumping opioids into this country the
the policies of the of the Democratic
and Republican establishment extracting
factories and jobs from this country
overseas to make a quick buck and the
prison industrial complex and we can all
see it and then the only thing we get
is the left saying communism is the
answer more government more police
officers more money for a big Pharma
more money for the big prison Industries
more government intervention in our
daily lives which is insane I do support
using the government's uh Power to
disrupt the Monopoly of making
pharmaceutical commercials legal I would
like to the government to make them
illegal like they did with tobacco
commercials in the 60s or whatever it
was the 70s
um that is maybe a little socialist in
me but I think that there's a time and a
place heavy Hammer of the government to
prevent these private companies from
taking over that's that's not socialists
that's that's something we can do
reasonably as a people as a community as
a country as a nation and be like here's
what we agree and underground how these
companies should function I think
regulations are fine the problem is when
they never get removed and they're
outdated or broken in some ways so what
ends up happening is Clause exactly yeah
we say okay we're going to try this out
we're going to do a two-year you know uh
ban on pharmaceutical commercials or
something and then we'll see how it
happens and if it's and then in two
years it sunsets and then you know we'll
have to re-vote for it or something like
that and all the politicians got bribe
for two years by the farmers industry so
that when they vote next time no it'll
naturally Sunset it'll just disappear
the law will just be gone that that is a
big problem you know the lobbying and
all that stuff and and the promises
there's no real way around it because
they'll just be like look we can't give
you anything but when you're out in two
years we'll give you a high paying job
in in the company I just you know
it's not socialist to say
the present industrial complex well
actually it's it's anti-socialist or so
I should say the government subsidizes
private prisons
guaranteeing cust like contracts so
you'll get a dude who is is hooked on
opiates because he was prescribed it
they get addicted where they're in
extreme pain they don't get any more the
doctor says no you're cut off and they
become desperate they go through
withdrawals and they could die from this
and so then they they they they you know
they seek out non-legal methods for
obtaining this to help themselves then
they go to prison and the government
says we got no issue with that private
prison system here's somebody to throw
into the machine and we will pay you for
it and what's happening is our tax
dollars are paying for a broken machine
that is not helping these people that is
only incentivizing this so I'll tell you
this that's not capitalism
that's that's that that's that's more
akin to Communism and socialism than
capitalism the problem is
first of all most conservatives don't
talk about this they don't seem to care
private presence is not a big issue for
them Trump wasn't you know interested in
prison reform but when the left brings
it up they're like this is a problem of
capitalism and I'm like what about the
government taking the money from the
People by force to fund these corrupt
prison systems is capitalism and and
creating absurd laws that put innocent
people that didn't harm anyone behind
jail in jail I mean that absolutely
makes no sense I think a perfect meme
that I saw that represents the larger
ideas that you're trying to get across
here Tim was a protester screaming that
we need more government and then there
was a full-on riot cop with pepper spray
pepper spraying her in the face and then
the pepper spray was more government and
uh she was getting all of it because
again you look at this kind of
reciprocal cycle they create all these
stupid laws that create victimless
crimes that put people in jail when they
shouldn't be there they come out worse
criminals they they come out destroyed
they come out without having uh you know
their rights they come out without you
you know a sense of decency they come
out in a situation where they can't even
probably get a job in most places it's
not always the case but again they
create a situation that incentivizes
some of the worst behavior in this world
and then we're asking ourselves why do
we have one of the largest prison
populations we wonder why it's it's a
big business and people profit off of it
speaking of victimless crime's brother
this morning I was looking at uh certain
reports that were released from Austria
showing that starting in February people
who don't take the vaccine might be
incarcerated yeah those are still
preliminary those are still preliminary
reports but we do know for sure there's
going to be a four thousand dollar fine
starting in February for those people
who don't get vaccinated this is
mainstream news not conspiracy at all
it's incredible it's incredible that
they can exercise that much control like
across Europe you're seeing that like in
Slovenia the small European country they
dabbled with the policy that um people
who are filling up on on gas had to show
their covet certificate otherwise they
couldn't get their gas but then there
was so much backlash that they
backtracked afterwards but looking at
Austria the Czech Republic Lithuania and
I believe Berlin Germany as well are
considering mandatory vaccination
otherwise paying fines or even
incarceration it's crazy in the U.S in
1905 there was a Supreme Court ruling
that stated you could find someone in
your community if they don't get
vaccinated the fine was five dollars at
the time the equivalent equivalent of
about 150 but that was it that's the
argument used by many of these leftists
to say see we've always had vax mandates
and I'm like yeah I guess but they were
never able my understanding is they
weren't able to collect the money from
them that was the issue he said he's
like I ain't paying you you can't do
anything about it so I mean sure I guess
you can argue you can find someone but
they can still say no the ultimate issue
was that they could try to compel you to
do it but ultimately could not force the
needle into your arm now the narrative
on the left is like we've always had
vaccinated what about schools and it's
like you can choose not to go to the
school you can choose to move your kids
you can get a medical exemption a
religious exemption now they're outright
saying like Jim Cramer just have the
military mandated in Australia they're
look I I think it's fair to say the
Australian press and all these people
are lying through their teeth and at
this point I would actually say that's
that's in my opinion circumstantial
evidence to suggest everything we think
about what's going on in Australia is
probably a lot worse than it is they
they admit they arrest three teenagers
from escaping from the quarantine
facility okay if that's the case and
Claire Lehman and whoever else wants to
argue that their international arrival
Bungalows where people like hot babes
are sunbathing but then they'll also
tell us you'll be arrested if you escape
I can only assume that it's
substantially worse than probably just
flogging people in their rooms I'm
kidding by the way I really don't don't
think they're doing that but if we know
they're lying about everything why would
I even just give them the benefit out in
any capacity so to me this kind of
smacks of an authoritarian government
because I remember when covid first
started my friend looked at the numbers
and said oh this is coming out of China
those numbers are 10 times what they're
telling us and I was like yes absolutely
so like what you're saying right now
what Australia is admitting to is going
to be very much a PR stunt the fact that
they're coming out and saying oh no you
know people aren't you know being forced
to do this or whatever and sending all
these awesome pictures of ladies in
bikinis very strange advertising for
these camps but it's like you're hiding
something you need to fess up and
they're never going to because they'll
never be held to account which is a
little bit discouraging but at least the
fact that there's a marketing campaign
with women in bikinis and government
quarantine camps is creepier than the
fact that there is that there wasn't
it's just the hashtag apparently yeah I
but but the fact that people were
collecting these and making articles and
making stories about this justifying
this bigger power grab by government and
not trying to hold the government
accountable not even talking about
personal responsibility is absolutely
worrying and uh we're seeing a lot of
crazy stuff happening in Europe Greece
just made the vaccine mandatory for
everyone over the age of 60. it's pretty
much mandatory in Italy already it's
pretty much mandatory in France but it's
not really implemented because people
are not going along with it but in Italy
right now you can't board a plane you
can't board a bus you can't board any
kind of public transportation you can't
have any job public or private if you
don't go through uh the government
compliance and you get their approval
and you get a paper saying hey I'm okay
with being able to you know bow down to
government then you could actually do
all of those things
let's let's bring it back from Europe
and Australia to the United States we
have the story from The Huffington Post
excellent source of news I'm being
sarcastic by the way fauci says Omicron
I'm sorry omnicron may not be big deal
but U.S should prepare for the worst he
said the covid-19 variant was inevitable
will inevitably come to the U.S if it's
not already here and warned that it's
going to have an advantage in
transmissibility it will never end
he says this is a Clarion call as far as
I'm concerned of saying let's put aside
all of these differences that we have
and say if you're not vaccinated get
vaccinated if you're fully vaccinated
get boosted and get the children
vaccinated also
Director of National Institute of niaad
said that though there is still much
that is unknown about omnicron it's it's
actually Omicron but we're making fun of
Joe Biden just so you know vaccines
often offer a proven level of protection
level they say a level of protection
sure but that's why he's saying get
boosted because the efficacy has waned
and there and as we already mentioned in
a previous segment the modernist CEO
says you gotta maybe gotta get two so it
will likely turn into more than that
quote it may not be as good as
protecting against initial infection but
it has a very important impact on
diminishing the likelihood that you're
going to get a severe outcome from it I
don't know ask Dan bongino he said he
got a really bad you know reaction from
it and he's double vaxxed yeah well here
we go SF Gate reports San Francisco
reports first U.S omnicron case symptoms
very mild all right very mild is good
but um prepare for the worst says fauci
what's the worst
well well I can imagine for most people
the worst would be a lockdown right yes
drawing whatever it's whatever each
person wants to imagine it's their own
Terror it's their own fear he's putting
people in a state of fear prepare for
the worst possible thing you can think
of the best fear that the government
could have is the fear of the unknown
and the more kind of uh unknown that
this is the more people's imagination
plays on the on the best of them
including the larger guilt trips the
emotional manipulation the trauma-based
mind control I like to call it is
essentially what people are going
through fauci by the way was also joined
by Obama yesterday and they did a
surprise visit at a DC elementary school
and they were meeting students and
encouraging them to get the vaccine uh
and congratulating the children I think
parents should be talking to doctors and
I I'm really what irks me about this is
that you can't give medical advice on
YouTube Joe Rogan gets slammed in the
media for for saying his opinion on what
he received Joe Rogan does there's a
video where he's like here things I got
and they're like and then I do a video
I'm like here's what I got here's my
thoughts like nah and then they can come
out and say oh yeah we want to encourage
you to take all of this stuff we don't
know your medical history or not but
we're going to encourage this particular
treatment for you I'm like no no no we
don't play that game you don't get to
argue that you get to advertise your
Preferred Medical assessment you know
treatment and then everyone else who
might bring up their opinion on it gets
banned end of the day anybody who just
blindly goes for any medical procedure
without consulting a medical
professional they trust and perhaps even
getting a second opinion is making a
mistake in my opinion did you uh see
what Bill de Blasio is saying to
encourage kids to get vaccinated a
couple months ago I think 100 bucks yeah
100 bucks and he was saying you can buy
a lot of candy with it you can buy Lots
such a creepy way by the way with kids
sorry I'm gonna go ahead no no I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna come down right to
it and say I don't I I'm I we need to we
need to stick to the freedom argument
personal Liberty individual choice
because what's happening is man we're
just slowly being pulled further and
further into into the mandates will
happen no matter what because what
happens is every day the media comes out
with a new Sensational fear-mongering
story a new thing that gets everybody
who opposes the mandates arguing about
that we are being dragged leftward and
more commercials about the drugs that's
something I'm thinking about I'm worried
most about young people right now with
the vaccine with mandating it and I
mentioned the 44 000 kids in La they're
going to start mandating in more and
more schools more and more kids are
going to be kicked out and pushed to
online learning where they're not going
to have those real interactions that
promote growth in all sorts of ways but
I I've interviewed several experts about
vaccinating young people including Dr J
batachary at Stanford
um Martin kildrof at Harvard multiple
doctors and they say that the
myocarditis signal in young people is
especially concerning according to CDC
data I gave Lydia the link also in the
email
um in the in the email but according to
CDC data the risk is about one in five
thousand
um for uh young men specifically in
between the ages of like 12 20.
um and so vaccinating so one in five
thousand may seem like a small risk but
once you multiply that by millions of
doses then that adds up and then you
have and by this is no exaggeration in
my own City in Chilliwack I've heard of
three cases of young boys who after the
vaccine had and a seriously adverse
reaction and were in the hospital
because of cardiac arrest due to the
vaccine I'm not saying don't get the
vaccine for your kid doctors you know
that I trust say if your kid has obesity
you know you should consider it or they
if they have cancer underlying
consistent things like that when it
comes to healthy young boys though a one
in five thousand risk is not trivial and
we shouldn't be mandating it at all I I
think I I this is what I want to get to
against like there should we shouldn't
manage anything we shouldn't mandate
chips we shouldn't mandate vaccines I'm
not saying chips are happening calm down
media but we have the story for the New
York Times we briefly showed the FDA is
assessing whether the moderna vaccine
can cause heart problems in adolescence
they say the fda's review viewing
reports suggesting the coronavirus
vaccine made by moderna can cause heart
problems in some adolescents the company
said on Sunday this is not conspiracy
this is literally moderna saying we have
these reports the FDA needs to review
this Moderno requested authorization
from the FDA for its using the vaccine
from children's children ages 12 to 17
in June the adolescence would receive
100 micrograms of the vaccine the same
dose given to adults 18 and above but
the agency has not yet made a ruling on
the application prompting speculation
about reasons for the delay in a
statement on Sunday moderna said the FDA
requires additional time to evaluate
recent International analyzes of the
risk of myocarditis after vaccination
okay so if fauci and and Obama want to
go to kids and say go do this and the
FDA is literally like we're going to
review these reports International
reports about myocarditis it is
extremely irresponsible and this is what
pisses me off I'm not going to recommend
anything to anybody but I certainly
think it's fair to point out the New
York Times has reported this this is a
month ago they reported this and the FDA
is going to be evaluating these claims
and these claims exist now by all means
when you talk to your doctor show them
this and make sure you get sound advice
and if you don't trust your doctor get a
better doctor but the idea that
politicians are going to go out and
advise people on medical procedures to
me is just insane and more importantly
as an expert on freedom I don't care
what you want to mandate freedom there
you go I have a right to my body my
autonomy and we just had the Supreme
Court we probably should have
highlighted the Supreme Court's
basically ending Roe v Wade This is the
official narrative across the board from
left-wing journalists to establishment
corporate press that come June Roe v
Wade will be done and we'll talk about
that in a second
and my attitude is look I don't like
abortion uses contraception I don't like
the idea in any capacity that a life is
being destroyed
but I air on the side of the government
ain't got no business in my medical
decisions or others and that means if
somebody has a legitimate reason they
have to undergo an abortion I don't
think they should have a certificate
filled out or have to get approval from
the government for a medical procedure
their doctor recommends but it should be
through a private doctor that being said
I feel the exact same way about all the
mandates what pisses me off is that we
don't have that consistency among the
left when the right came out and said
okay my body my choice they said you're
Liars we don't believe you
yeah also quickly I want to say about
the myocarditis risk one of the
interesting things is that the science
doesn't change in terms of risk of
myocarditis from country to Country yet
the policy is completely different so in
the U.S and in Canada you have the um
well in Canada specifically you have the
policy where young people over the age
of 12 in BC and in Ontario have to be
vaccinated otherwise they can't go and
exercise to a gym they can't go to a bar
restaurants Etc
um and and from starting yesterday you
can't leave Canada because of the
vaccine mandates
um but in other countries with young
people what they've done is in many
cases they've suspended the moderna
vaccine because of the higher rates of
myocarditis as that piece was pointing
out by the way I think I actually uh I
have this here Sweden Denmark Finland a
number of other countries moderna
October 8th CNBC Nordic countries are
restricting the use of modernist covet
vaccine the decision to limit the use of
modern vaccine centers around concerns
it could be linked to cases of
myocarditis so this is moderna organizes
it yep the FDA is looking into it Nordic
countries this is this is all fact and
very also also they're finding that
myocarditis is concentrated after the
second dose in young men not with the
first as much and because of that
countries like Hong Kong and the UK are
only recommending one dose to young
people so think about that because other
countries who have their own legitimate
Health authorities are saying young
people get one dose okay but countries
like Canada you have to get two doses
otherwise you can't go to the gym in La
if you're a young person you have to get
two doses otherwise you're going to be
kicked out of in-school learning that's
crazy it's the same [ __ ] science but
totally different public policy sorry
was I no whatever man you were talking
about a puck right like in Canada
that's how AIDS is too though they can
measure um HIV but then every country
has kind of has a different response to
that and that's what their age thing if
you have pneumonia in a certain country
and you have a Thai T cell count
political it's politicized right it's
the science is not just one thing you
can base policies off of this science
that's growing by the way I like how the
the left like they view science as a
very religious kind of system like
science are supposed to be you know
constantly evolving and updating as you
see new information like this whole
myocarditis risk was not known when the
vaccines were initially released right
but then we saw data from Israel coming
out and Alex Bernson was talking about
this and other people and they're like
no no that's conspiracy like heart
inflammation come on that's total
[ __ ] but then more and more
information came out more and more
studies there's also stuff happening
with menstrual bleeding in women after
the vaccine I don't know about that
stuff though I looked into that I didn't
I didn't find anything on that well yeah
I know I sent Lydia link Lydia if you
want to look at that that was I I say
something about that issue specifically
so a friend of mine in July
um she's uh 17 or 18. she said her she
had this horrible menstrual bleeding
after the vaccine and I told her it's
probably not the vaccine like come on
there's probably something else right
and then another other young female
friend told me and then I heard about it
from another one and then I started
asking around and I kid you not almost
everywhere I asked among young females
that's a weird thing to ask women bro
yeah yeah I know I know of course being
a reporter yeah but but I'm reporting
how was your last cycle
but I've heard of at least 20 young
girls like girls who tell me like yeah
all my friends they had the same
reaction which is like crazy and
um the NIH is actually funding research
right now into looking at this specific
risk with menstrual bleeding in women
here's and then also the guardian and
the New York Times have reported this
that in in the UK in their adverse
Reporting System they were inundated
with reports of young women having this
menstrual bleeding issues so it is a
real thing that is being investigated
therefore another reason why mandates
are stupid and rushing vaccines have a
risk we always have to make sure we
consider what I refer to as the scaling
problem that as a system grows larger
the tolerance for error grows smaller so
if you give out 100 vaccines and one
person has an adverse reaction nobody
cares oh I heard Jim had a weird
reaction oh just Jim huh no problem but
that's one percent you give out 100
million vaccines now you have million
people all talking about these stories
and everyone's like what's happening a
million people had this same percentage
of error as the system grows larger our
tolerance for error diminishes you know
proportionally so what may be happening
is that a lot of people are like look at
verse the numbers are through the roof
for Adverse Events and I'm like yeah we
also haven't had Mass scale vaccinations
globally or in the country like this too
so make sure you're looking at margins
and not hard numbers it would be like
looking at New York City and being like
wow they had 10 000 muggings that's the
highest in the nation and then being
like yeah but per 100 000 people they
have substantially less muggings New
York's got like 10 million people in the
Metro then you can look at these like
small towns where per capita they have
like 50 muggings like in West Virginia
they have seriously high crime but very
low population so you'll get like 50
stories about muggings and you won't
think twice about it and then in New
York you have everyone you know has been
mugged it makes you think it's worse
than it really is so it's important to
look at the the the denominator
especially not just the numerator I am
not saying ignore the data I'm not
saying ignore this I'm saying saying
literally take all of this do research
seriously ignore the mainstream media
when they're like don't do your own
research no do your own research make
sure you have have trust in yourself and
your knowledge bring it to a doctor you
don't trust them you get a second
opinion but make sure you know what
you're putting in your body because I'll
tell you this if you just go to someone
and say tell me what to do and I don't
care I'm not going to think twice I
think it's a bad idea I think you have a
responsibility for your health and I
also think you have responsibility to
seek out experts which is your medical
professionals and find someone you trust
but it's a combination of things man and
all the liability is on you here
um the people who produced it the people
who forced you to take it your business
your boss your government is not
responsible they have no liability here
at all if something goes wrong and there
have been stories of a lot of people
who've had problems and again uh you
know correlation does not prove
causation we need to be intellectually
honest here uh there's a lot of things
that are still unknown here but a lot of
people who had complications were left
with huge medical bills because they had
to pay for all all the problems and
consequences that led up to this
decision that was essentially forced
onto them and when that happens you're
making the decision that you're going to
be responsible for no matter what
happens and no one's going to bail you
out all right
now we're going to get into the portion
of the show that I saved for near the
end because I knew it would consume
probably the rest of the show would be
like whenever we talk about Roe v Wade
or abortion it like turns into this
major long conversation and so I was
like if we open with this it's going to
be an hour of debating abortion so I
don't know maybe we should if it's the
bigger news here but um ladies and
gentlemen
from CNBC Supreme Court conservatives
look ready to gut Roe v Wade during
arguments in Mississippi abortion case
it was today Mississippi wants to ban
abortions after 15 weeks and the Supreme
Court heard oral arguments and boy did
the left have almost no argument uh look
you guys know me I'm pro-choice I am not
pro-abortion the modern left in my
opinion is pro-abortion not pro-choice
and pro-choice is few and far between if
exists at all I think the pro-choice
individuals have more in common with
pro-lifers but they do disagree
I heard some of the arguments you could
listen to it uh chief justice Roberts
made excellent points and he did compare
the US to other countries and he still
made good points the left seemingly had
no real argument and it got to the point
where a reporter from Slate tweeted the
argue the arguments are in the Supreme
Court will overturn Roe v Wade in June
2022.
he then deleted the tweet and said too
many people thought it was a statement
of fact he said what I'm saying is it's
a prediction these are leftist reporters
the NBC News tweeted it appears the
conservatives are going to repeal
something I'm paraphrasing repeal or
strike down Roe v Wade there are 12
states with what's called trigger laws
which means as soon as Roe v Wade is
overturned they instantly go into effect
they've already been passed an abortion
will be immediately banned It is
believed that many more States will then
ban abortion and you will have blue
states that allow it red states that
don't the Supreme I'm not trying to say
it again
we don't know what's going to happen it
might not but based on what these the
justices were arguing
Kavanaugh man he hit it out of the park
and I have to agree with him he said you
have like he pays I'll paraphrase he was
like you haven't presented an argument
as to why this is a an issue for the
Supreme Court this sounds like something
the Congress needs to address
and I'm like he's right
the Supreme Court shouldn't be deciding
whether something is banned or not
banned Congress needs to pass laws
legislating the stuff on that alone
and also listening to the argument from
the solicitor general who is like
defending uh um Roe v Wade
she was just saying like the right to
abortion is in the 14th Amendment and
and I think it was um Clarence Thomas
was like
what I can read the second amendment
that says something I I can't I don't
know where what you're getting at with
that so so yeah this uh this seems like
the end I know Luke Luke was celebrating
earlier I don't know about that I saw
some weird videos on Twitter today of of
women taking uh I think it was abortion
pills claiming to yeah claiming to or
doing it I don't know but it it's such a
complicated debate there's so much
emotion involved in this it's and and I
don't think people celebrating abortions
is is something that is tasteful to say
the least it's something that was very
concerning to see and you know there's
there's different uh aspects there's
different places where you could be on
the Spectrum here and there's a and
there's of course people arguing that if
you do take an abortion you are killing
a life and therefore you are trampling
on somebody else's life so that's where
the argument gets common all right look
I like so what's what's your position uh
I need I I honestly want to do more
research into this I don't want to make
a a conclusion because it's a question
that's very difficult to answer and not
having done enough research on it I
don't feel well versed to expose any
opinions on it so be completely honest
with you so what you're saying is you're
sitting back as babies are being
murdered and you're okay with that
there's a nice fence that I see here no
no it's nice to sit on some
but being honest here you know there's
things that I believe personally and
there's things I believe the government
should be involved in
um I don't think the government should
be involved in in anything but people
are arguing that when you're committing
an abortion you are killing another
individual and that argument is
compelling to a lot of people and I I
think it should be an argument that
should be talked about more
well I think cut off time is important
like after how many weeks and I remain
hesitantly pro-choice on this issue I I
don't really publicly share my opinions
on this like Luke here
um but but I think um I think it's uh
what is it 12 weeks for when the baby is
a heartbeat I believe that seems to be
potentially a logical cutoff like after
12 weeks then potentially maybe we
shouldn't be able to or maybe a bit
after that I don't know but it's a
matter of having a reasonable cut-off
point
I know Luke's trying to be careful here
but the reason is is you know before the
show he actually confirmed to me he's
pro-death not actually pro-life at all
he's like send them all to the camps to
the good looks uh there's no there's no
there's no fence on this issue it's one
of the hardest issues it is ethically
yeah but I was I was you know reading a
lot about Roe v Wade and um the initial
rulings basically the idea is
oh man insanely complicated
you can't uh what they're saying is they
don't want you to be able to abort after
the fetus is viable because at that
point you're dealing with a
self-sustaining independent life before
that the baby is not able to live
outside so so um how many weeks are we
talking 24 20 24 uh on and I guess
initially during the initial arguments
in Roe v Wade it was like 26 and Beyond
was viable and now with metal technology
it's gone on 24. and so you know
pro-lifers are basically like don't
abort for any reason and what's
happening at Mississippi is they're
saying after 15 weeks you can't get an
abortion John Roberts was talking to
um her name um
what's her name I can't remember her
name the solicitor general and he was
like if you're talking about the issue
of choice I don't understand how 15
weeks is not adequate time to make a
choice and she did not have an argument
and he brought up European countries he
said in many European countries they
have you know less time than we do and
then she lied and said no they they
allow abortion up to the point of
um
viability that's not true and it's not
true at all yeah Europe is actually very
strict I think 12 weeks yeah why have
they chosen 15 by the way here what's
what's the rationale behind fifteen
that's the heartbeat right yeah I think
so 15 is around the time 15 16 around
the time I thought it was 12 for
heartbeat but maybe maybe you're right
maybe I think it's also important for
people to distinguish what they believe
personally and what would they rather
have the government do personally I'm
not a fan of government uh but
personally if I had a situation where
you know I was potentially having a
child I would do everything in my power
to have that child and I would do
everything to make sure that there
wasn't an abortion
um personally speaking from my own
personal perspective so that's what I
would do there's an interesting argument
in this whole debate that that basically
came up and it's if a woman is pregnant
with a baby and the baby is not able to
sustain itself
then
I don't think it's it's the state's
right to determine that someone has to
share their body with someone else but
the issue for me is if someone has to If
a woman has to go to a doctor and the
doctor says something like look you've
got this you know problem it's a serious
health issue and it could kill both of
you and we're worried about this
understanding the argument because I've
talked to Sheamus from Freedom tombs a
lot about this a lot he's like doctors
can be wrong about that and often will
pressure towards abortion but um Assad
that argument aside if this woman has
has an art a serious medical issue it's
traumatizing it's it's serious I don't
like the idea that she goes to the
government and seeks out approval or
paperwork however if we're at a certain
point where on average the baby is
viable you are now asking to terminate a
sustainable life form you you are now
saying to the government I would like to
kill this this life okay at that point I
think it's even absurd that you can go
to the government request termination of
someone else if the baby can live
outside the womb then I don't understand
why we don't just say okay well we're
gonna take the baby out of the womb and
let it live well what's what is life I
mean just lay there in a cradle until it
starves to death or are we having
someone take no they put it in the
premature baby incubation someone's
gotta feed it and like take care of it
someone's got to start mothering it
immediately when it's removed from the
water these are tough more questions Ian
what's the alternative we say we have
this baby we have a let's say you have a
nine month A A full term baby fresh out
of out of the the womb and then and then
you're like well who's gonna feed it
yeah I won't so what do you do well
there's also there's also a lot of
people who can't have children and wish
they can have children and they wish
they could adopt but are adopting
adoption system is absolutely crazy to
the point where many Americans are
literally going to China and Russia in
order to get babies there because the
process is so much easier and simpler to
do it over there than to jump through
all the government Hoops here in the
United States that actively intervenes
and and you know some would argue
prevents people from being able to adopt
children here in the United States so
there's also Arguments for that as well
and again this is a very difficult
discussion a lot of emotion here
um you know life you know how does it
begin I mean it's a conception that kind
of story life is you know precious in my
opinion so let's be preserved at at all
costs I'm not I'm I this is a very
sensitive issue and we already got a
Super Chat where they're like long story
short terms hypocritical or hypocritical
for opposing the death penalty but first
for being pro-choice I am pro-abortion I
think killing is wrong I think using
abortion as contraception is disgusting
the problem is saying to the government
you have a right to to be in the
doctor's room with person with a person
to demand their papers I don't think it
should be effect allowed for for for
vaccines I don't think it should be
allowed for when you have to go to a
doctor and you say yo my life sucks I
have a serious problem and I and I think
about the challenge here in that there
are a lot of women who are crying saying
please please save my baby and after
saying ma'am I can't it's ectopic it's
not gonna work and then he's like now in
order to save you fill out this
government form and go talk to your
local politician about why this is what
you need to do I don't like the idea of
the government being involved in that I
certainly despise to a great degree that
people abuse the system to be like
accidentally got pregnant instead of
using birth control I'll just kill it
that's screwed up that's bad and wrong
and then I sit there like with my head
shaking like how do you reconcile this I
cannot entertain the idea of the
government being given authority over
our bodies and and having a right to be
in these medical rooms there is an
interesting argument though about the
time duration this is a there's no
middle ground here this is the challenge
here I think killing is wrong I think
there are certain circumstances where
you have to it's unfortunate Kyle
Rittenhouse shouldn't have had to kill
the people he did but he was defending
himself and I don't think he should go
to prison for it and I wish those people
didn't lose their lives no matter how
awful they are sometimes you have no
choice if there is a woman who has a
serious medical issue a legitimate one
I'm not talking about stupid lies or
arguments or whatever I'm talking about
legitimate like yo the heart is busted
up and it's not going to survive and it
might kill you too and the mother is
crying begging for help saying please
don't let this be true and now she's got
to go to the government for approval man
screw that I'm not all about that I I
think that's ridiculous that Cal
Rittenhouse had to justify to a court
with a threat of life in prison because
he was simply trying to save his own
life and I view the the issue is very
similarly when it comes to legitimate
arguments from women who are dealing
with this stuff it is very very
difficult to reconcile I can fully admit
hands down Michelle wolf and Lena Dunham
these people sicken me when they're
celebrating this stuff and cheering for
it and women are staying outside of
courtrooms taking pills mocking it but
the problem is you know I'll tell you
this is a problem it's really simple
a pro-choice position is is ridiculously
close to the pro-lifers they're both
saying man we really hate this and the
pro-lifers are like well we don't want
there to be any excuse for why they're
going to get away with doing this and
many of the pro choices the legitimate
ones are like man but getting the
government involved and then you have
the pro-abortion people which is the
modern mainstream left and they're
celebrating this trash so look I don't
want the death penalty I don't want
abortions I recognize sometimes people
die I recognize sometimes their
abortions I don't have all the answers
morally but I just don't like the
government getting involved in people's
business yeah I think also to add to
your point I think you're absolutely
right and it's important to look at
costs and benefits for when implementing
a policy you can't just look at the
benefits and the costs or sorry just the
benefits or the costs when it came to
covet people are all about lockdowns
lockdowns but and obviously they save
lives that's true when it comes to covid
but when it comes to the economy then
it's totally different calculation so in
this case you know allowing you know
being pro-choice doesn't mean that
you're pro-abortion it's just that you
think that government mandates and
government power in this case is more
dangerous than certain people abusing
that choice so you're looking at the
cost and deeming that to be more
dangerous than the benefit there's an
interesting potential argument here as
well what if there was no government
involvement in any abortion but the
doctor did have to have a legitimate
reason how about that that's a good idea
well you know there's there's different
spectrums here and I think one of the
worst ones was what happened when a lot
of very powerful eugenicists in the
United States implemented a one-child
policy in the United States and had a
situation where the government there was
forcing people to have abortions because
they didn't want them to have more than
one child so that's the the inverse of a
situation where the government got
involved in abortions but made it
mandatory for almost everyone to take it
if they wanted to have a second child
there's also a lot of very dark history
when it comes to Margaret Sanger plant
uh Planned Parenthood how it started a
lot of letters by Margaret Sanger that
are absolutely troubling that are
absolutely worrying and when you really
delve into a lot of government
intervening in this specific realm I
think it highlights a very Sinister dark
past that is worth conversing and
understanding before kind of jumping
into uh this position because I think it
does play into the government's role
here these are this is such an
impossible it is moral conundrum it is
yes I mean let's let's imagine a rape
victim someone who was not irresponsible
someone who did not make that choice who
is now being told by the government you
are you are obligated to share your body
and blood your bodily autonomy is hereby
revoked you are now you know to to
provide for this other life the girl
wants to kill the baby she's gonna kill
the baby whether the government tells
her it's legal or not we've had I've
heard anecdote stories of people going
like back alleys to get these black dark
abortions under the table illegally and
like she gets hurt during the thing
because it's not done on the on the up
and up she takes some sort of injury
like you're not going to stop it it's
been going on since the dawn of humanity
whether we've been destroying babies
that aren't viable like they come out
and they have their crippled or
something and they would kill the baby
and then the Spartans man yeah they
would just like leave it in the woods
right and see if it survived to play
Devil's Advocate on that argument though
like that um from what I've read the
rape cases are only about one percent of
cases for abortion so well right so so
some people say that you shouldn't base
policy based on the one percent of cases
I don't think rape is an excuse for
killing a baby for terminating the life
I think the problem though is there's a
lot of very serious philosophical
arguments about responsibility and
choice a lot of people immediately go to
how could you be against the death
penalty but for abortion it's like
there's completely different
philosophical philosophical arguments
there I think you're mansplaining too
much Tim what about the guys who who get
pregnant and what is the what does the
woman here think about this debate Linda
oh boy Luke uh you uh you triggered a
firestorm here because I've been sitting
listening and I've been thinking how
wonderful it is that I've been able to
maintain my silence as long as I have
this is like my hill to die on this is
what I really care about you're correct
that I have vanishingly small number of
abortions are in fact committed because
they are a result of rape or incest I
use numbers from The gutmacher Institute
which is what uh Planned Parenthood uses
for their numbers so they err on the
side of maybe trying to pump those
numbers up to kind of support the idea
that abortion is actually medically
necessary and I agree with Tim because I
know people who are the result of rape
and they are wonderful people they were
adopted by people who care very much
about them and of course they would much
rather be alive then be dead and and
that's why I said right I think the
conservatives who argue the rape or
incest exemption I don't understand that
at all yeah I don't see how it's the
baby's fault that they were conceived
however there's a there's an issue of
someone being forced to share their body
with someone else so if the government
came to me right now and said we're
gonna hook up your blood to Ian because
Ian needs your blood to live I'd be like
hell no right and they'd be like well
you should have been more response I
didn't choose that right so that's the
the personal autonomy problem further
the problem arises that yeah one percent
is you know but and so I think it's 99
isn't it like 99 of abortions are no
reason given elected yeah either no
reason given Orlando I think I think I
think it's I think abortion as
contraception is wrong but I don't know
how you deal with it then when someone
can walk in there and be like right
yeah and then what do you do to the
actual rape victims who are like you
can't force me to share my body with
somebody else I didn't choose this I
don't have the answers man I think I
think one of the most compelling
arguments on the pro-life side is what
Luke was alluding to earlier
um and I've looked at the data on this
that there is actually higher need for
adoption than there is actual supply for
when it comes to very young children I
believe that changes for for kids after
the age of like six like there's an
abundance of kids in foster care homes
who aren't able to find parents to adopt
them but when it comes to really young
infants from what I understand there's a
huge huge need but it's not met with the
same level of Supply so arguably you
could say that we should
um you know have pro-life policy and let
people give birth to kids and give it
off to adoption because there are so
many parents gay couples also who are
looking to adopt and it's very very hard
because there's a very very low Supply I
do think that one of the things that we
could do to help solve the problem of
abortion is to reform the adoption
system make it simpler so
one of the problems with Roe v Wade is
that it never should have been
legislated at the federal level because
what they found was that abortion was
becoming more socially acceptable before
they passed Robey Wade if they had gone
state to state and said do you guys want
to worship and each individual state had
used their 10th Amendment rights to say
we do want it we don't want it because
this is not in fact a Duty Left To the
federal government by the Constitution
thereby meaning it should be left to the
state there are no emanations and pin
numbers in the 14th amendment that say
that a woman should be allowed to remove
her child's body from her body by force
necessary so I think that um we are
you're correct that it is very nuanced
and I hate to see leftists being so
insane but I thank them for making my
case for me because no one can look at
these women standing on the steps of
this building taking these abortion
pills and just shouting their abortion
it's filibonti uh from All That Remains
tweeted that if there's one issue that's
going to push moderates to the
conservatives it's the issue of abortion
because the leftist argument on all this
stuff is like I mean it's evil it is it
it is absolute it is amoral it is
unethical it is it is evil they don't
treat life with value right and look I
get it when they talk about moral
relativism oh yeah I think it's a real
thing and I think when you have a bunch
of people who lack a moral framework
they have no problem literally killing
burning down buildings and celebrating
it and we've seen that with the riots
all throughout last year 25 directly
dead as a result of the George Floyd
riots and not an ounce of remorse in
fact they still celebrate it when uh
when um was it Aaron Danielson that was
his name the guy in Portland who took
two to the chest yeah they cheer for it
yeah when uh what happened after
Charlottesville everyone on the right
mourned and said this is terrible we're
we're shocked by this it's because you
look at the moral foundations of these
people and they don't have any we talk
about you know care and fairness now
whatever the moderate modern leftists
are they are just a chaotic destructive
force they have no principles there's no
logic I'm not talking about literally
everyone on the left I'm talking about
the weird cultist woke whatever cheering
for death taking abortion pills
celebrating the stuff that's just a
moral outright and to me overtly evil my
issue is just like wow I'm trying to be
good I'm trying to respect everybody but
boy is it hard when you have a woman who
is an autonomous life form with rights
and a baby who is an autonomous life
form with rights and how do we reconcile
that with what the government gets to do
Ben Shapiro brilliant argument that if
there's one thing the state does do it's
protect life in which case when it comes
to the issue of a child a baby which and
life does begin a conception any any
other argument otherwise is a ridiculous
political argument uh then the
government should be involved in whether
or not life is terminated now I want to
address that one very very seriously
because there look
when when the spermine they had come
together you get unique DNA and from
that point on there is a unique set of
DNA that is New Life the new life is now
created when we had vosh on the show he
was talking with Charlie Kirk and he was
asked when does he think Life Starts
he's like uh birth and I'm like so if
the baby is not born from the woman it's
like not alive but you can you can have
a baby at eight months be removed via
C-section and it's and it's alive and
self-sustaining why is birth the point
what is traveling through the vagina and
the vulva have to do with whether or not
this baby is literally living I've heard
from people that say three months three
months is when Life Starts because
babies can't remember anything before
that and I'm like so people who have you
know serious Amnesia issues or
short-term memory issues and can't
remember things aren't alive it's a
ridiculous argument life begins at
conception that's it's just it's it's
it's a political argument to say
otherwise moving on from there you have
a very serious conundrum of who gets to
decide when a life is is terminated I
don't like the death penalty and I don't
like abortion but I recognize death and
you get a couple of skin cells in a
Petri dish it's alive it's not a human
I think that's when does it become a
human is the is the debate
I think if is the skin going to uh grow
and become unknown well the answer is no
Ian you don't know it's still no we do
what do you mean
when does the baby in in utero become a
human like at what point do we say it's
it's alive for inconception I agree
living muscle tissue but at what point
do we acknowledge human is it heartbeat
is it a brain three weeks I think nine
weeks 12 weeks well it's not really
human at that point yet though so this
is such an interesting argument because
if you watched a dog sperm meet a dog
egg would you ask the question is that a
dog would you there would there be any
doubt in your mind that a little puppy
would result from that Union probably
not I don't understand why we do this
with humans it's it's it's it's you know
the reason I disagree with you is that
it would be like looking at a child and
being like it's not it's not a human
because I mean we don't know that it'll
become a mature adult who can reproduce
no it's a zygote if you look at a zygote
your doing a different stage of human
life doesn't mean well you don't you
don't know what it's going to become yet
when you're looking at a zygote you
don't unless you know that it was a
human sperm an egg or a dog sperm and
egg you don't know what it's going to
turn into so I think in Ian's defense I
think the differentiation you're trying
to make potentially is in terms of like
pain perception potentially you could
say like for like at what stage does the
does the you know fetus like feel pain
and it's actually different I mean
arguably then that argument is like
Terry shivo remember that whole thing do
you remember that a person in a
vegetative state isn't alive
oh what if someone's in a coma they
can't respond to stimuli you're just
like meh they're dead similar you have
no idea if they'll come to and then a
week later they wake up there's still a
little bit but sperm and egg versus an
actual fetus that has a heartbeat like
in terms of feeling pain after you
terminated I'm saying I don't think pain
is relevant to the conversation of
whether someone has rights there are
people who literally can't feel I'm
saying arguably in terms of suffering if
we're measuring based on suffering but I
don't think we are okay like if if an
old man is comatose you know guy in his
60s is comatose he has he has rights and
I think there's an interesting question
about do we have a are we obligated to
give him life support and the answer
that is probably no but we can and maybe
it's the right thing to do I don't think
healthcare is a human right if there's
someone lying on the ground in the woods
in their comatose you can be like they
will die like without assistance from
someone else they have no right to it
but we do want to save them when it
comes to uh like so my point is that
pain is not relevant to whether or not
we want someone to live or they have the
right to live anything like that just
because someone can feel pain or can
suffer doesn't mean we let them die we
usually choose to preserve life but
obviously there is a difference morally
speaking there is some difference there
I don't agree in terms of how much harm
you're inflicting on just a uh an egg
and a sperm versus an actual fetus you
know 20 weeks in I guess you know
obviously there's a difference I'm not
I'm not saying that that's a big
difference it is fair it is fair to say
that we treat we we do as a culture
treat
um fertilized eggs very very differently
than we would like an actual baby if a
woman you know has a fertilized egg and
then miscarries and doesn't know what
happened and just you know it just flush
out of the body no there's no murder
trial there's no murder investigation if
she gives birth to a baby and then
something happens and the baby dies in
the crib the cops are going to come and
try and figure out what happened so
there's a certain point where the
government would intervene and wouldn't
intervene that being said I'm not I
think the government is doing a heck of
a bad job and that's why I don't like
them I don't like the government in the
system in a lot of ways and a lot of
things they do so one of the things that
I was going to add to Luke's point from
earlier was that but I feel like a lot
of this would be resolved if we reduce
the size of the government and reduce
their overreach if we kind of scaled
back the involvement that they have in
the adoption process if we scaled it all
the way back from telling what the woman
what they can and can't do if we left it
to doctors if we left it to mothers but
I at the end of the day I have to say
that I genuinely feel that um this is a
cultural problem and I need to fix the
culture figured it out what you just got
to pull Trump a big ask right here's
what the big ask is nice yeah so a big
ask you you know read art of the deal
right that's what that's Trump's book
right and it's basically like you know
maybe I want to sell out or what's a
good example I want to um
I want to buy I want to hire you to do a
job
and so what you do with the big ask is
you'll say okay I'll do this job you you
what you really want is 50 bucks but you
know if you start with 50 I'm gonna
negotiate down so you say I want 500 and
then I go whoa whoa that's crazy and
then you go well 500 is my number and
then I say I can't I can't do that and
you go okay fine what if we do three no
no three's still nuts well now you're
getting me down a lot bro will we do 250
all right 250. the big ask is you ask
for way more than you want so you
negotiate down to where you really want
to be it's simple all we have to do is
have someone campaign on forced abortion
oh that way everyone freaks out the
China policy China Ted Turner liked that
one uh so did uh Bill Gates's dad who
was connected to Planned Parenthood
again there's so much things I can talk
about interesting but uh that's not a
policy that that's too absurd to him
that's a policy that many people have
argued for they're doing it right now in
China in the uyghur camps yeah well
these are these are you know you know
everyone needs to realize because
someone brought this up they said that
uh viability is actually you know
getting uh like at 15 weeks there's been
a case where a child you know a 15-week
you know fetus has survived and so with
modern technology eventually abortion
will be made illegal because a
fertilized egg will be viable in right
technological settings think about what
that means when it comes to
transhumanism these arguments are going
to get crazier and crazier we don't even
we don't even know because when we talk
about forced medical procedures like
government mandates I brought up earlier
today and I have to at Star Trek when I
think it was Data talking to Jody
laforge for those that aren't familiar
data is an Android he is physically he's
a robot I mean he's Superior he's
stronger he's faster he doesn't sleep
and Jordy has uh cybernetic eyes he's
blind so he has a prosthetic visor he
wears that gives him enhanced vision
and he's asked I think it's by data I
could be it's been a long time since I
saw the episode but he's asked you know
are your eyes Superior to uh regular
human's eyes and he says well yeah he's
like I can see x-rays infrared and then
he says then why is it not mandatory for
all humans to have those implanted in
them and it's like well because people
you know have individual autonomous
rights when we get into the policy where
it's like the the covet vaccine is going
to keep you safe and keep others safe so
you have to get it and I'm like yeah so
we're wearing a bulletproof vest 24 7.
are you going to mandate that yeah as we
develop technology viability could
become like a day you could have an egg
and a sperm meet and they're like we
have the technology to now gestate this
in a machine and then it's going to be
like you citizen you are required to
deposit your sperm as per government
regulation like how you're doing that in
China they have sperm catching machines
at hospitals that literally men walk up
to and they have a huge population what
someone corrected me it was data and
Picard
no this is important I'm sorry
it's the episode I think it's called
make of a man where this is the
philosophy of the show is brilliant
data's an Android and they're trying to
they're questioning whether or not he
has human rights whether or not he has
civil he's worthy of civil rights or
he's just a washing machine or he's just
a computer and so he says to pick hard
he's like are jordy's eyes not Superior
to you know human eyes and he's like
well yes and he's like then why is it
not mandatory making a making important
point about bodily autonomy interesting
I would argue that Chinese man-sucking
machines are a lot more important than
this kind
personally myself that's what me and Ian
were just talking about you know we have
a population crisis and and the Chinese
have literally developed man sucking
machines that take out the sperm and
they're they're building databases on on
women and fertility in Beijing it's
absolutely crazy what's happening in
China because of that one child policy
that has absolutely really messed things
up socially in China uh but that's a
whole other topic
all right it's a good one let's take
super chats if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to the
channel and go to timcast.com become a
become a member we have a members only
segment coming up around 11 or so p.m
but let's read some of these super chats
and uh Josh Martinez says for goodness
sake Tim that a single pro-life person
has ever said you should have to
petition the government to get an
abortion not ever
well um let me ask you Lydia How would
how would would there ever be a
circumstance in which abortion is
allowed if it under your ideal system
yeah
yeah there is uh there is one instance
in which abortion should be
possibility
um and Sheamus disagrees with me on this
uh I think and this is what my parents
thought as well they were even way more
conservative than I am If it threatens
the life of the mother that's it how how
and so if it's illegal in all other
contexts how does the mother get that
abortion performed
there's an exception I don't know I
don't know so but but so will the doctor
just be like I've decided there's an
exception and we're gonna do it no or
the doctor have to get approval from the
government yeah so typically I would
imagine that would be more than one
doctor would need to confirm that this
is actually the case like she had an
ectopic pregnancy
um and then from there on they would be
like they would I don't know I don't
know if they'd have to go to the
government it might be like a county or
state thing where they'd need to submit
a request and then go through and figure
out what to do I think it's it's
entirely possible to argue it's just
three separate doctors from three
separate practices you know three
independent you know are confirmed by an
Arbiter an Arbiter there has to be an
external party is the issue right
someone else because you could have
three doctors who collude and be like
we'll work together and just claim the
same thing and no one can stop us so you
would need a third party in which case
who appoints the third party and
regulates them my issue is I don't see a
way this is this is accomplished unless
there is government regulation directly
involved and someone working at the
behest to be the Arbiter right I don't
like the idea used to be I do think
there needs to be some level of
organization like that and this is
making me wonder if there's any other
kind of procedure that they do in Haas I
know I worked in a hospital but I didn't
work in administration so I don't know
if there are other procedures that you
have to ask the government if you can do
something that would be interesting to
look into I'll check that out I mean
maybe it really is just the compromise
of we recognize some doctors might
collude but we accept we accept it as
reality yeah in which case there doesn't
need to be government involvement there
just needs to be three doctors who
confirm and agree but then man there's
still the challenge of the individual
who says this is not an issue of your
responsibility or Choice I'm being
forced to to you know carry another life
against my will I think that at the end
of the day one of the nuances we need to
look at is the fact that we're not going
to be able to make a perfect system
unfortunately and I think that's just
something we have to live with
unfortunately you know maybe uh maybe
what we do is we just create uh Ultron
yeah there you go the way to bring about
peace in a perfect system and to end all
human Strife is to end humans like like
like like Bender says and Futurama you
know all humans yeah I think Bill Gates
would agree with us
Bill Gates is watching Futurama and he
watches Bender go kill all humans and he
goes I like this guy
the coaster guy says bold of them to
assume the military would run it well I
was vaccinated through my job in the
guard they lost my records twice and
then reprimanded me for not being
vaccinated wow I love I love people who
just believe that uh the government can
run things properly obviously like these
leftists who are like we want Universal
Health Care and it's like imagine the
DMV regulating your health care that was
like Kramer it was like we'll get the
military to do it yeah
come on dude have you seen the way they
administrate stuff he probably has it
have you been to the DMV oh man known
for it you know I gotta be honest the
DMV's out here in West Virginia are
pretty good they're fast it's not it's
population density that really really
messes things up you get in these cities
in New York it was a disaster I bought a
moped and I called and I'm like how do I
does this have to be registered yes and
I said how do I do it and they're like
just bring in the bill of sale the
receipt bring it to the any DMV will
take care of you and I went in there and
not a single person understood how to
deal with it they were all confused and
they were all asking each other and then
eventually they were like we can't do it
and then I was like then how do I ride
my bike without a plate and they were
like uh you can't and I'm like well it
sounds like a you problem and they were
like can't help you sir and so I was
like okay great thanks government now I
got to deal with cops who are going to
be like I don't care why right the law
is the law is so like basically mopeds
are illegal they're not by the way yeah
how did you resolve that I rode my bike
without a license plate um did you ever
end up getting one
uh no dang that's a guy
yeah well there so the problem was
I think I don't know the the exact words
of the law but because of the petals
that arguably it was a gray Zone and so
I was like look at the DMV tells me
there's no way to register it and they
can't and it's not illegal then I'm like
okay and then I guess I'll just write it
so there were pedals on it so they were
like it's not a motorcycle they told me
they did not know how to register it and
didn't think it could be done and thus
they didn't think it was regulated under
you know those laws or whatever and I
was like I'm pretty sure it is and I
have to do it and they were like well we
don't and we can't so we think you're
fine and I was like
I never got pulled over Dude smell like
baby diapers in there when you were in
there no those really they're really
deep inner city specific DMVs tend to
smell like baby diapers interesting the
Bob says FB is allowing Rittenhouse
Praise And discussion I wonder if
they'll remove my rolling suspensions
for sharing memes 30 days plus 30 days
plus 30 days each
yeah man
all right you think that's bad wait till
the metaverse hits oh boy oh you know
I'll briefly mention this too because
someone mentioned Lauren bobert I think
she very poorly handled the ilhan Omar
thing I think like dude you made a joke
that's it yeah and like Nancy Pelosi is
like and she's screaming I would be the
worst member of Congress ever if I was
ever in there because I'd make jokes all
the time and then they were like
apologize I'd be like just ignore it
and moving on and they'd probably kick
me out they legit would kick me out like
I wouldn't dress up I tell them to shove
off
I don't know I think Lauren shouldn't
have apologized I think she shouldn't
have to even tried I think she should
have been like haha I told the joke and
it you know I would have responded
yeah I know
Eric a says there's a clip from 10 years
ago of Jim Cramer talking about things
he would do to manipulate the market
when he was a hedgie said it required
someone to enforce the rules felt like I
had to take a shower after watching it
ugh
you see that hedge fund billionaire who
said there's gonna be a civil war no
yeah he's worth 20 billion dollars and
he said in the next five years there's a
30 30 chance of a civil war like
conflict in the United States seems
higher than that but okay he makes his
money off of predictions huh literally
his uh he's he's that's what Forbes said
he he places investments in bets and
then makes money off him and he's one of
the most successful guys doing it and he
thinks the civil war is coming oh boy
what a crackpot the stupidest thing ever
there's no reason for people to fight
I'm gonna say it
in the Civil War the American Civil War
there was a strong moral issue the north
despised slavery it was moral the South
it was it was an issue strongly of
convenience for them at state rights but
they didn't view it as a moral
repugnancy they were just like hey we
can do what we want people in the north
were legit like I will storm my way into
your state
and and literally kill people to stop
slavery there were a lot of
abolitionists who were like morally
driven
the issue of abortion let's say come
June 2020. they uh Supreme Court
overturns Roe v Wade all the red States
ban abortion all the blue states don't
people in the red States for the most
part those are pro-life have a strong
moral position it is wrong and it must
be stopped but the pro-abortion people
and many of the pro-choicers are
basically just like as a matter of
convenience I don't know I think it
should be allowed but whatever there's
no in my opinion there's very few people
who would storm into red States
demanding abortion facilities be opened
in which case if there is going to be I
think it's entirely possible that
abortion is a is a key issue which could
trigger very serious um civilization I
would imagine it would be government
overreach for coveted regulations if
anything was going to spark physical
violent conflict that it would be like
people kicking doors down trying to
inoculate Force inoculate people like
you can't take my guns or or mandating
like the third shot or the fourth shot
yeah in schools right to that point in a
year or two years then things could
start getting really a few months I I
can agree to a certain extent but I'm
not convinced it'll be rolled out the
way you think it I I don't think they're
gonna go door to door and pin people
down yeah right what's going to happen
is they're gonna you know they're gonna
create perverse incentives and things
like that yeah but the issue of abortion
is like
I mean I didn't Sheamus say this that
like abortion could be one day abolished
like slavery and viewed much the same
way I say the exact same thing it's a
strong moral position people are willing
to like it just doesn't seem right to
fight and kill to prevent killing what
do you mean that happened that that's
literally war is every war I mean it's
one thing to kill the slave master and
release the slave but who are you going
to kill to prevent the mother from
killing the baby the mother no you have
you have facilities that that operate on
a bunch of buildings they'll just do it
in other buildings we're talking about
war we're not talking about like who
they kill it doesn't make sense though
to fight to stop abortion who like how
do you how do you fight to stop slavery
I mean what would you do like burn a
farm down yes Sherman literally did
March to the Sea burning yeah five
owners from power so how so exactly so
you want to stop abortion what would
people do they would Target doctors and
facilities and Destroy them and of
course people slaves still exist at the
Civil War they had to send the the Union
Soldiers down to Texas and that's what
June was about it took like three years
to finally pick hey you're not supposed
to be doing this they still did I'm
saying I'm not saying it's right or
wrong or whatever your opinions I'm just
saying the pro-life people have a strong
moral position they say this must be not
allowed and the people who are on the
side of pro-choice and pro-life I'm
sorry pro-choice and pro-abortion
are not that morally convicted to it
that's for sure right it's just a matter
of priorities I think Freedom or safety
or life other people like people have
different values and so they have
different decisions on these complex
issues I'd like to hear from someone
that experienced the Roe versus Wade
phenomenon was went through it as a
female Let's uh that would be
interesting let's read some more we got
bugga off he says what do we call it
when someone tries to force something
inside of someone else by even by
coercion the Harvey Weinstein insertion
forceful insertion we call it an
international arrival Bungalow oh
Tara Tara Ann Simmons says isn't this
all a part of the Great reset
I believe so
it seems like it yeah I think I think
they're doing the rad experiment on us
and I mean that somewhat facetiously I
just think uh no no they are I don't
know if it's as intentional as I think
it's
I really don't believe as a grand
nucleus controlling everything like yeah
you know but I believe we for the
circumstances we're in will result in
the same outcome I I don't know if it's
relevant to be like here's who I think
is doing something it's happening
regardless we're under lockdown we all
freak out everyone loses their minds
they lift the lockdown everyone goes oh
thank heavens and now they're like
lockdown again but this time 10 times
longer and people are gonna be like oh
we'll get out of it soon I love the you
know the South Park episode I didn't see
it have you guys seen it I thought part
of it it's like I did it so it pretty
much pokes fun at the greatest side it's
amazing yeah it's incredible it's like
they're all adults children taken over
by VR there's like Chinese symbols
everywhere there's people like eating
bugs meat is banned I love that South
Park special it was good yeah and they
were and it was like 40 years later and
covet finally ends yeah no no no finally
finally just finally stops being
relevant in everyone's uh adults all the
you know all the four main Children
characters are all old and uh Cartman is
um
you have to
all right let's see
Mark sermon says true journalism
criteria all sources are linked no ads
Beyond self-promotion based on primary
sources not other articles tweets Etc
I think that's that's
um High tier yeah I think you can do
journalism but I do think sources should
be linked I think ads are fine to be
completely honest and I think based on
primary sources is
I would say nine out of ten nine out of
ten
um there may be some circumstances where
you have uh additional input but
99.9 of the time I think primary sources
and and that's because I don't want to
be completely absolute but
all sources should always be linked and
the challenge there is when you have
unnamed sources
I'm not a big fan I'm not a big fan
but if you have the trust I guess
I've had unnamed sources before so it is
what it is
true to another shop at a pressure
Medicare says my lifelong Republican dad
called me an anti-vaxxer today today was
a huge black pill rip American freedom
yeah there was that there's a clip from
that uh Gunner guy Michael Gunner and
North Northern Territories who's like if
you oppose vaccine mendix you're
anti-fax and absolutely and I
said
the the the most
um
scary thing about that is that he is
right technically as per the new
dictionary definition is that
anti-vaxxer now means being against
mandates or giving Aid Comfort or
support to people who are anti
anti-lockdown yeah if you look at the
actual like polls by the way like
Americans who are actually anti-vaxx
it's like five percent or eight percent
it's very very small but now you're
gonna have like a much bigger group of
now anti-vaxx like 20 30 or whatever it
is that actually oppose mandates or
maybe more than that
Ben D says you hear Baldwin says he
never pulled the trigger oh man should
we talk about that we talked about it a
little bit before the show yeah he's
lying he's a liar an actor it's possibly
a kind of gun that goes off just from
pulling the hammer back and letting it
go there's a possibility for that as
well well that's a that's a malfunction
he has a single action revolver you pull
the hammer the the you know the cylinder
spins and then the trigger is ready to
be pulled
I think you know it may be possible that
Alec Baldwin doesn't understand when you
pull the hammer back the trigger goes
back and so he didn't realize that it's
like it's like a hair trigger it's like
you tap it
and the other question is um uh you
didn't pull the trigger but you pulled
the hammer and pointed it at this woman
and the gun went off it's like bro I I
don't I don't care if you did or did
whatever you believe like you pulled out
a gun you pointed at a person you pulled
the hammer back it went off somebody
died and when trauma goes down people's
memories sometimes blacks out so he
might not remember pulling the trigger
or he's just saying what he has to say I
just want to go to prison for sure
definitely yeah he was crying like he's
legit crying his eyes were all puffy it
was bad
all right let's see we got
uh Talon's Andrew the microchip
semiconductor industry is pushing
mandates all over the country
semiconductor workers need help fighting
back please help get the word out we
have a petition on change titled save
semiconductors
um you know I think people should do I
think just get all your buddies who work
in that field and just start your own
Factory man
I mean it might be it's not going to be
easy but start small and just start
working on it I'm down if it's possible
I'm not saying it is wrapping
semiconductors definitely possible but
let's just create that parallel economy
they want so dear you guys want to make
some turbostratic graphene with me there
you go make superconductors a user named
Emmanuel Goldstein says are we going to
address the elephant in the room that
Trump was on the Lolita Express and as I
stated as per Mr Bill Gates if you're a
wealthy Elite and you are flying on the
Lolita Express and it's called the
Lolita Express I can only assume you're
doing one thing and that goes for Trump
same as it goes for anybody else yeah I
made a video theorizing what happened to
Trump and Epstein on my Luke uncensored
video uh but I I think you know I I
think you know it's an extortion
operation it wouldn't surprise me if
Trump was caught up in the extortion
part and come on like the way Trump
talks about women paying would you pay
100 grand for Stormy Daniels he gets
invited to the silence team as anybody
else
that's a bad business deal and he he
wrote The Art of the deal I mean come on
someone else wrote it I think he put his
name on it I mean maybe yeah maybe ten
thousand but hundred thousand but hold
on I mean what's the guy worth he's a
billionaire he probably he probably
pulled out a random wad of cash and he's
like oh I got a 150 on me I'll give you
100. it costs them like 10 grand just to
count the money in hours that he's
losing in time yeah he probably just
threw away ten thousand dollars a minute
but yeah uh uh we we heard reports in
the Maxwell trial that Trump was very
much flying and uh the pilot I believe
called Trump uh Epstein's wingman saying
that like it was yeah with young ladies
and all that stuff I don't know Trump
gets no special treatment for me if Bill
Gates is on the plane then we're gonna
call him out I'd love to pull up a video
of trump stuttering and stammering if he
does you know what did Trump say about
Maxwell
trial yep which is a odd comment yup ask
dummy says might sound too silly but to
be honest I think the medium of air is
up for grabs really meaning who has
legal responsibility over the quality of
air in my lungs now or say at work is my
respiratory system an extension of my
400 pound co-worker who just eats all
day
yeah there's something really gross
about sitting next to some disgusting
person that's not taking care of
themselves just bro smelling up the room
I was on a plane once and uh it was uh
it was uh morion we were like on an
embryer A crj so they're not very big
they only have two seats on each side
and so it's one dude and he was probably
300 something 400 pounds and the lady
comes by with the food cart where they
sell stuff they have the snack box they
have the sandwiches and you know she
looks over at me and she's just like um
would you like to buy any any food and I
was like I'm good and the guy next to me
goes oh yeah I'll help the uh the poor
boy and she's like okay I also have
another poor boy
um I'll take two snack boxes oh do you
have chips I'll take two bags of those
do you have anything to drink I'll take
I'll take three Pepsi's yes three okay
thank you you don't have to open them
um and also uh do you have the nut
package I'll take another snack box and
I was I'm not exaggerating I was sitting
there like whoa and the dude I'm like
you're flying in the wrong class man
yeah this was a long time ago you know
uh good old days yeah when I when I uh
You Can't Always Get first class because
of availability but I'd often get
upgraded and then so then you're sitting
in the bigger seat now it's like if I
have to fly you know it's got to be
first class mainly because I work
Morning Show Night Show and then we had
to wake up when we flew to Austin it was
like wake up Saturday first thing I'm
like dude my head will literally fall
off if I'm dealing with the stress of
sitting in coach and having to deal with
that kind of nightmare oh it's that's
not it's it's it is people need to
understand this first class exists for a
reason true if you're flying just like
one time you're going on vacation I've
flown coach hundreds thousands of times
no joke thousands no problem but when
when I had to fly when I was working for
these companies like twice a week I was
like yo I literally can't handle flying
out flying on a morning and then fly out
at night and I'm like please spare me
dealing with this and so that's why they
have the rewards program so typically I
had five I'd fly first class because I
was like an Elite member I'd flown so
much these days I have like the special
you know I saw the special account or
whatever so I don't got to worry about
it I have like a million frequent flyer
miles
all right Mason Wolfie says 20 says
Federal military enforcement leads to
separation of states and the activation
of militia groups throughout the U.S not
saying it will just a guess
I think abortion is going to play a big
role in this I really do to be honest
I'm not feeling that
you don't think so no I look at like how
they they said what was Oklahoma's
National Guard they were going to turn
it into a militia like that to me is
federal government is saying we are
basically renouncing our authority over
you Oklahoma like if you're going to
start doing that to States states are
not going to take your uh your laws very
seriously Ben H says Trump did not focus
on prison reform with the first step act
the goals to reduce unnecessarily long
prison sentence improve conditions in
prisons and it uh he oh I'm sorry Trump
did focus on prison reform with the
first epict reduce unnecessarily long
prison sentences improve conditions in
prisons and enact post-prison
Rehabilitation programs I love it it's
fantastic yeah he released so many
people that were in prison for like
decades and they came out and they were
so happy and so grateful and I think the
programs to actually help rehabilitate
people is crucial like not just like let
them off on the streets and then commit
crimes again we know recidivism rates
are so so high the people who recommit
crimes like 60 70 percent it's like
actually giving people programs where
they can educate themselves or acquire
skills to apply them in trades like
Plumbing or electrician or whatever it
is that's very very important now now do
Julian Assange yeah maybe maybe you're
right maybe what we should do is um at
the first sign of any potential crime we
put you in solitary for the rest of your
life interesting just instantly without
that trial just we'll do you ever see
Judge Dredd you ever read it yeah yeah
they're judged during executioner right
there on the street it's faster it's
easier very fast it's actually a really
interesting concept too we were talking
to Andrew branca the law of self-defense
and he was just talking about how
there's too many criminals for the
courts to effectively deal with them my
response is like that's too bad for the
state if they don't have the time to
have give a hearing release them it is
better that 10 guilty persons Go free
than one innocent person suffer from
that idea though you end up with someone
writing Judge Dredd well because there's
too many criminals make the judge and
the the cop and the jury one person who
can go out and judge people
it's a cool sci-fi concept man yeah it
was pretty cool luck and uh what's his
name well they did the new one with oh
with Carl uh Urban no I haven't seen
that yeah I think yeah yeah that was
Sylvester Stallone it was a little
cheesy yeah yeah he's definitely got
potassium though I like the concept and
flying cars yup just straight up killing
people I don't know man it's an
interesting concept as to the the the
the you know congestion not something we
want to have I would like to see webcams
more utilized in prison and maybe for
people that have an interest in learning
a trade they could do it on the internet
and take classes every day and then you
could have like prison guards watch them
just just don't leave James comey's
daughter uh in charge of that project
you know we should talk about
um white Anderson says Tim and crib the
second Civil War happens uh would you
fight or be a will be War correspondence
uh
I mean neither
well I mean I I guess keep doing the
show yeah I don't know I don't know why
that would change unless YouTube was
like oh your opinions are bad and we're
in a civil war so they delete us or
something we probably just keep you know
doing the show I think we should
definitely talk a little bit about this
um because I think it was slate wrote an
article saying which side are you on the
second civil war is coming and they were
like we're not saying it's a guarantee
but who will which side would you it's
time to choose like it was a crazy
article and it showed like a proud boy
with a mask on or something and I'm like
man you're crazy information is key
during war and that's why through before
many wars start all uh dissemination of
information is usually centralized by
the state so if there was a conflict I
don't think there would be things like
YouTube and open debate and discussions
I think all that would be out the window
immediately Salon wrote it in this in
the coming second American Civil War
which side are you on
I think that's so reductionary because I
don't think that they're just going to
be two sides right there's a look at the
photo that they decided to put up with
this oh wonderful I think it looks like
Bane yeah yeah but like America Bank I
like it though does he have a shield can
we scroll down a little bit no that's
funny he does have a shield yeah so yeah
man um you know what I think I think
we'll we'll we'll talk about that in the
uh
we'll talk about the member segment
we'll get into a lot of that stuff and
uh we'll just read uh one more here Mark
B says why no comparison to the vaccine
mandates to the number of the Beast it
is here uh we've talked about that we
talked about how it says that are you
familiar with was it Revelation yeah
Revelation yeah no ass is it it's
singular uh oh right yeah I've heard
about it the mock of the Beast you would
not be able to buy sell or trade unless
you had the mark of the beast I didn't
know that yeah and then someone super
chatted it to us and I was like what the
Bible would talk about trading or
selling like in that context that's
weird well yeah I know like Christians
don't even I didn't realize that but the
mark of the beast was just like a sign
you were a member or something and then
I read it and I was like oh yo that's
crazy
um err on the side these days that
interests are are using the story of the
Bible in Revelation and then making it
happen as opposed to like it was gonna
happen all along that's where that's
where I'm at now yeah ladies okay
gentlemen if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to the
channel go to timcast.com we're gonna
have a member segment coming up around
11 or so P.M every day there's a huge
library of content if you haven't
already signed up you definitely should
because it helps support our work and
man at this point we have what hundreds
of members only segments you can watch
about a variety of issues behind the
scenes content as well the Green Room
show here at the studio behind the
scenes as well as Tales from the
inverted World we're just going to make
keep making more and more awesome stuff
for you so go check it out and you can
follow the show at timcastirl don't
forget you can also follow me personally
at timcast on Instagram and you know
basically whatever else or have you want
to shout anything out yeah I just
started a sub stack to write about
psychedelics meditation spirituality
ravarora.substack.com I'm trying to get
more and more subscribers so I can write
about my experiences on MDMA DMT
psilocybin coming up in the next six
months and hopefully share with readers
these experiences so that they can have
their well we'll talk about that too in
the membership Ian's ears sparked out by
the way his eyes went up uh most of it
yeah I've only puffed on DMT I've never
gone broken through yet
um I also have my own YouTube channel
it's youtube.com forward slash we are
change I was translating German again
today I had a lot of fun with it people
really enjoyed it it was absolutely
Bonkers and totally facetious and if you
want to see it again youtube.com forward
slash we are change hope to see some of
you guys there thanks for having me
thank you guys so much for coming I'm
Ian cross on checking out Ian
crossland.net if you want to check and
get get in touch with my socials catch
you later
thank you guys for bearing with me and
my impassioned arguments about pro-life
as I always bring if you guys would like
to see more of my insane uh but
well-researched arguments against
abortion you are more than welcome to
follow me at sour patchlets on Twitter
so um a few minutes before the show I
was uh pulling up on my phone my Google
Drive and I was talking to some of the
people here we're working on recording
some more music so we've got some guests
here and I was like let me see if I can
find some of the recordings I have maybe
can send you and so I went to my Google
Drive and I searched for music and then
this music folder pops up and I click it
and I see a bunch of names of songs I
don't recognize and I'm like what is
this I don't know what this is like and
so I look and there's like lyrics and
I'm like what what I didn't write this
what is this and then there's a video of
this like dude with like short brown
hair and some like red guitar and I was
like what the hell is this and I play
the video and I don't recognize this guy
at all and then he starts singing and
I'm like that's Ian that's a good song
That Song Is Hot yeah anyway thanks for
hanging out we'll see you all
timcast.com in the members only segment
bye guys